pop
[Musique]
il est l'heure de réveiller monsieur
andré j'ai travaillé très tard je vous
en supplie ne me réveillais pas avant
que je sonne a pour le coup à le
réveiller au souffle du printemps
puisque ses victoires à ses vertèbres
madame de quoi de massenet madame bon
vous avez réveillé monsieur andré non
madame écoutez victoire je vous ai déjà
dit lorsqu'un 11h30 - office n'est pas
élevé je veux que vous entriez dans sa
chambre aux ouvriers ces vidéos mahdaoui
j'étais précisément en train de frapper
chez monsieur andré mec que madame
regarde j'ai travaillé très tard je vous
en supplie de me réveiller pas avant que
je sonne alors faut-il tout de même que
je n'en sais rien je m'en occuperai moi
même bien madame vien sait pour quelle
heure le déjeuner 12h45 oui est ce que
je vous ai dit que monsieur le rémois
déjà mais aussi à non madame non alors
ça fait 6 couverts en tout oui c'est
charlotte la cuisinière qui va être
contente
amélie a battu voilà qu'elle aurait tout
11h45 pourquoi 23h45 c'est pas possible
regarde ça ne me réveillais pas avant
que je solde à a
il a passé des noms alors faut pas le
réveiller faut pas le réveiller on
souffre du pardon faux réminiscence
eugène et nous avons du monde à déjeuner
bon alors tu 70 me rendrai à faire sa
toilette
il va nous faire manger à une heure et
demie tout ça tu as raison fall réveillé
il faut le réveil théréau sauf du prince
non il faut le réveiller c'est bien vite
dit tu connais andré pour moi suffit
qu'on interrompe son sommeil pour qui
souhaite une humeur de chien mais c'est
bien pour ça que j'ai dit à entrer dans
sa chambre
autant que possible qu'il fasse bonne
figure à nos invités cela surtout à 9,6
oui faut pas le réveiller faut pas le
réveil thériault
et puis d'ailleurs il a dû travailler
très tard ce petit travail et ça fait
quoi il est chroniqueur sportif à la
revue verte revue mensuelle paraissant
deux fois par an on apprend qu'il ya la
trinité c'est l'occupant dans mon avis à
moi la plus verte a bon dos et que les
chroniques d'andré son final il excusait
noctambulisme qu'il est lui un chronique
notre fille tu serais là lol comme si tu
n'en n'était pas aussi sûr que moi on
n'est jamais sûr de rien voir
montaigne et rabelais montaigne et
rabelais il pas rater a mis à dos tout
en couleur à tout un monde à part une
tête dormir comme ça enfin vous pourrez
peut-être essayé de réveiller sans en
avoir l'air bag sans entrer chez lui
mais en faisant du bruit ici
le photographe quand il s'en apercevra
ils sont aussi furieux que si tu
attaques à nous tirer par les pieds mais
n'ont pas besoin du phonographe
on pourrait parler un peu fort oui comme
convenu ça n'aurait pas les convenu tu
comprends comme dom donc dans le feu de
la de la conversation en cause ans tous
les deux on aurait pu avoir élevé le ton
sans nous en apercevoir auquel si
mclaren
quand je pense que c'est pour notre fils
que nous prenons en mourant mais j'ai
des photos si tu l'as eu avec une
faiblesse avec sun n'a pas gâté autant
que moi c'est pour le réveiller du
sculpteur jamais de la vie
c'est toi qui lui passait toutes ses
fantaisies et je sais bien je suis trop
mauvais j'ai tort j'ai tort monsieur
m'appeler
mais même pas du tout pourquoi ce
monsieur n'a pas créé victor victor mais
non mon ami nous essayons madame et moi
de réveiller ne suis rentré en élevant
un peu le ton alors allez à vos affaires
au plus tôt et élever la voix avec nous
pas bien monsieur a bien monsieur aulas
et sortez vite bien madame nous sommes
bien nous on n'est pas en tonnes vendues
domestique
tu n'as pas dignité tient aussi
magnifique but c'est leur avis - 9
c'est bien j'entre un lit quoi tu as
raison vas-y entre mecs je t'en prie pas
par le lui tout cela ne le met pas en
colère on écoute laisse moi faire elle a
l'esprit de décision ma femme elle n'est
pas comme j'en fait georges était une
petite couturière
ce que je voudrais place blondel quoi il
n'y est pas mais qu'est ce que tu veux
mais je dis qu'il n'ya pas mais c'est
pas possible tu as mal regardé pour que
nos bons vieux que l'on vous avez
l'histoire il souligne même pas d'effet
son pyjama et là c'est sa chemise de
nuit es6 pauthe
on voit surtout tu y es excepté nuit oui
enfin ça vaut mieux qu'il y était avec
quelqu'un voit ça ne te feras pas toi
moi toi tu crois un accident mais nous
ma chérie on nous avait prévenus rond je
crois que ton fils a fait la noce et
qu'il a découché j'en suis même sûr
alors je n'ose pas de joie m en veux tu
as raison notre fils a des couches
aisées
ces formules c'est honteux il met
bientôt fils ensuite eu peur d'être
fiers et arrêteront voilà c'est mon fils
m'a quand ses mots
bonsoir bonjour le rémois c'est l'heure
des moines et c'est comme ça depuis
trente ans chaque fois que nous avons à
nous louer d'andré celle son fils chaque
fois qu'il a fait une bêtise c'est le
[ __ ] une pétition à rien entraîné par
entrée de la nuit qu'est ce que vous me
dites la méritante vérité mon cher nous
faisons entrer dans sa chambre il n'y a
pas comme n'y est pas et n'y est pas
mais on peut t'il bien là à ça je ne
connais pas l'adresse de ses maîtresses
c'est embêtant parce qu'on aurait pu
téléphoner
eugene où serait pour lui rappeler
l'heure il a publié est ce qu il lui est
déjà arrivé de ne pas rentrer coucher
mais c'est la seconde fois de l'hiver
mais enfin nous sommes le 3 janvier
raison de plus dans sa conduite est
scandaleuse
enfin le rémois scandaleuse tu entendre
mais il croit mais qu'est ce que tu veux
que je fasse qu chaque mini-jeu
l'enferment à double tour et puis s'en
tirer par la fenêtre est pas dire ça
fait deux ans que ça dure ce garçon à la
noce dans le sorte quoi il a un os dans
le sang
la noce dans le sound ça commence à
m'inquiéter il a mauvaise mine il
maigrit faut absolument qu'ils changent
d'existence le premier pli comment le
plus le pli est pris d'assaut
ce sera difficile mais ne dit pas ce
sera difficile à mon nom je crois que
j'ai trouvé un moyen un moyen comme il
n'y a pas d'ordre est assez vidéo parce
qu'ils s'ennuient chez nous il n'a ni
frère ni ses homélies trop tard
maintenant il faudrait pouvoir aux gens
rejettent avec toi tu pourrais personne
qui est sondages où ses goûts non rien
qu'une mère souvent trop gras voulons
relever souvent bien content et un père
car excellent à la cervelle d'oiseau
laisse moi parler tu veux donc il faut
quelqu'un qu'ils aiment qu'ils
comprennent qui le dirige adroitement
sans en avoir l'air on a moulé foot une
femme je crois savoir qu'il vous a pas
attendu
je pars d'une femme légitime vous voulez
marie andrée qu'est ce que vous en dites
pour la malheureuse est pourquoi cette
semaine aujourd'hui parce qu'andré est
fait pour être marié comme moi pour être
à bascule parce que vous le disiez tout
à l'heure à ce qu'une seule commande
parce que passe-t-il et l'a9 dans le
sens parce que c'est la conduite il
régularité l'inexactitude en personne
parce qu'il faut que jeunesse se passe
et enfin parce qu'andré destinée à voir
encore une longue série de mes toiles il
serait préférable pour le marié
d'attendre la fin de cette série ce sont
là toutes vos objections à kaunas mais
non mais non c'est la pendule il est
midi midi c'était covanta étape à
rentrer mais si la fin ne ramènera
maintenant est-ce que vous tous les
corps andré est en âge de se marier
on se marie à tout âge c'est le tour
qu'on sait si difficile de coller à
temps quand on est jeune il est trop tôt
quand on est vieux il est trop tard
entre les deux entre les deux réfléchi
si vous supprimez le mariage à présent
vous savez le rémois vous êtes un vieux
révolutionnaire un vieux célibataire
simplement emploi décrié mais plein de
formes mon lit n'est pas grand mais je
bois d'amont vers ça doit pas être là
vous me croyez donc bien et respecte moi
oui incapable de faire le bonheur de mon
fils je crains surtout pour celui de sa
femme mais ça dépend qui elle serait ça
j'ai pas trouvé une femme
il s'agit de trouver la faille il vous
l'avez trouvé une oiseau rare la femme
idéale jeanneteau bailly qui vient
déjeuner l'esma terrain a précisé ben
oui vous la connaissez un peu oui je les
ai vus l'été dernier en vacances à
houlgate avec vous et les jantes et les
délicieuses à 18 ans orpheline
recueillie par son grand-père armando
béni le vrai le grand historien 2
l'académie française qui l'a élevé en
dépit du bon sens un esprit du diable un
toupet mons aucune tenue bref une petite
merveille et le grand père est au
courant de vos projets on va bien
entendu il les approuvent
écoutez le rémois est ce qu'ils
viendraient déjeuner ici dans l'intimité
avec sa fille de filles si nous n'étions
pas d'accord
et l on parle de lui en parler bien
entendu
non mais vous savez le rémois que armand
d'aubigny de l'académie française est
passée quelqu'un à sa base
ça a été le cas mais aujourd'hui le
rapport nous avions dans notre famille
une des gloires contemporaine lalieux
déchets sans compter que s'il se marie
andrée héritera de la fortune de sa
tante
la comtesse de pré-en-pail et qu'il ne
nous coûtera plus à cela c'est vrai ce
adore le rémois voilà une nouvelle
qu'est ce que vous en dites moi je dis
que ce déjeuner plein d'intérêt mais qu
il en perdra beaucoup si andré n'est pas
là qu'il fait est que c'est affolant les
dons bini vont être là dans une demi
heure en quarts qu'est ce qui peut bien
faire dehors depuis hier soir pour moi
maintenant il doit dormir donc
l'existence
ça c'est téléphone avant oui c'est
peut-être lui ça tu as raison les vagues
non non mais c'est lui de rentrer
immédiatement pris un club menace mais
qu'il rend beau el fahm d'activité ça
mais non j'y vais moi même c'est plus
sur ma concierge un petit garçon de sept
mois qui marche tout seul
j'ai peur que ce mariage ne passe pas
comme lui
[Musique]
ne fatigue pas en effet il ya longtemps
que tout le monde est réveillé mais tu
mettais le 3 juillet déjeuner et
déjeuner mais quelle heure et qui
dormait et 12h10 00h10 guise de la
droite montre donc j'avais perdu à cette
nuit bah oui je crois qu'elle étourneaux
et yamagata montrent beaucoup là tu
trouvé dans les mains de la petit plus
c'est petit bisou du ces petits bisous
emon avait chipé oui pendant le souper
chez maxim's battue était déjà un peu
mieux tu t'en es bon aperçu tout d'un
coup j'ai vu que la petite petit bisou
avait tellement l'autre alors ça devrait
demander pourquoi la vraie elle m'a
répondu que c'est parce qu'il la
trouvait jolie au dessus de lui dit que
ça ne suffisait pas elle a paru très
surprise
elle m'a dit que quand il trouve quelque
chose je me on le lui donne toujours un
enfin dans beaucoup parlé il a fini par
me la rendre mais une autre fois faute
ans sur les balais dans quel monde
quel est mon nom était l'heure du parti
de chez maxim's toi je t'ai même pas vu
temps d'aller en leur tapant tu sais moi
point qu'il arrive quand une personne je
vais me coucher
et vous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
boire pas grand-chose vers 2 heures on
s'est aperçu qu'on s'embêtait alors on
est on est ressortis on s'est empilé à 7
dans l'auto de fouchard on est on est
monté à l'abbaye st sinistre alors on
est repassé par le pré catelan tasse de
lait classique et puis je suis entré
chez gabriel bas évidemment si gabriel
au par exemple suis un peu fatigué way
toi moi toi du tout c'est patent ton art
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça à mon art
à genoux en tout cas rentrait à 12h tu
trouves ça résonnait en moi quand sa
pitance et mes parents bon moi si je
déconseille je rentrais à 8h à la
personne n'était encore levé je me rends
compte avec la bonne qui posait le
vestibule
comme j'avais des relations avec elle
elle peut vous
c'est dépôt vente enfin on peut ne pas
avoir de relation avec la bonne alors
envie de te sens où pour qu'elles ne
disent rien c'est moins cher c'est moins
cher
il a catapulté par an les vols à vide en
jeu fils tu m'as pas plus aux normes
internes au cendrillon pays tu apprends
tout flou et merci tu m'appelles au
l'autre merci tu vas tu va maintenant
c'est par andré qui téléphonent à
belgrade
pourquoi notre mission mais savez-vous
qui téléphonaient non le gérant de chez
maxim san jose mine
non je le connais un peu comme ça parce
que j'y vais avec georgette nom georges
est est monsieur ed
le président de son conseil
d'administration on va et d'idées fois
par mois 20 etc et qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient et vient nous prévenir que
londres était parti de chez maxim cette
nuit vers 3 heures en oubliant payer sa
dette qui s'élève à 326 enfants
champagne et gaufrettes en nous priant
de réserver un bon accueil au maître
d'hôtel qui viendraient ce matin nous
présenter ce que trois fautes chez apple
l'a pas du bois fait tout cas pas
évident allemand ou alors il va rentrer
un peu souffrant parce que cet ami
histoire non papa papa de paul minutes
non du tout je suis outré avec qui
pouvait-il bien mais ça avec qui avec
des gens qui avaient soif alors tu sais
toi tu es fils vraiment or voilà c'est
mon fils et mon fils a raison
le rémois je n'ai fait tout seul tu
étais impressionné non ce n'est pas lui
la saq ne se soit pas déjà lé noviny ça
c'est pas le terme de la porte d'entrée
non mais non c'est la somme des
bourriches ans pour les domestiques
le rémois qu'est-ce qu'ils n'avaient
jamais vu - il est rentré pour l'oc ii
téléphonions chez y être enfin parvenue
est solide et il est rentré mais il
sonne alors ça va
le café au lait du monsieur andreï sony
vient de se réveiller remporter ça a
bien mahdaoui parce que le café au lait
sur trois enfants de champagne savoret
malades dont je suis sûr qu'il ya pas
entièrement france qui s'occupent 1
c'est avec moi il sait ça c'est moment
sa maman peut pas par nous je crois
oh et le rémois ces deux rémois et ça va
il dit a bien dormi pas beaucoup d'armes
à fois tu sais le sommeil du match sont
entrés dans ta chambre
alors qu'est ce que tu disais le sommeil
du matin ah oui de l'ironie 1-2 le fouet
de la satire castigat ridendo mort est
là mais c'est amusant on savait qu est
ce que tu dis ah non mais vous me faites
marcher on est d'accord c'est très drôle
et bah oui là je viens de rentrer voilà
c'est ça vous vouliez savoir voilà vous
lit pour ces cui la caisse m
c'est une lettre au monsieur de pour
tout savoir pourquoi tu as passé la nuit
dehors oui pourrions-nous savoir
pourquoi tu as passé la nuit dans un
week end le savoir du don
mais mais mais parce que j'ai été obligé
j'adore mon livre j'ai horreur dormir
n'importe où si je rentre à cette heure
ci c'est que j'ai matériellement pas pu
faire autrement
d'ailleurs le mot le mot impossible et
français si tu savais ce qui m'est
arrivé raconte un peu pour voir
on vous y raconte un peu peur mais c'est
c'est très sain c'est très facile c'est
très simple c'est idiot mais c'est très
simple voilà voilà voilà voilà
alors alors
eh bien d'abord je le ferais remarquer
que les habitants boulevard beauséjour
les matchs là-bas quand c'est calme
c'est avéré c'est silencieux c'était les
gangs en face aux diables instant
auteuil alors d'âme quand quand il ya
plus de métro et à des taxis grippe
non non justement il n'y a pas de taxe
il y en a pas on croit comme ça qu'elle
est taxi payant n'a pas la preuve c'est
que cette nuit je suis resté sur le
trottoir sans en avoir un comme en
quarante cinq minutes montre en main
montre en main habilement oui montre en
main et vous montrer
alors au bout de vos bout de 45 minutes
j'ai fini par trouver un drapeau blanc
enfin ça m'était égal
moi ça va être légale mois pour rentrer
chez mes parents je suis capable de
n'importe quel sacrifice vous me
connaissez alors je lui ai dit
voulez-vous me conduire et il m'a
répondu moi je voudrais me conduire
seulement je verrai gare de l'est
alors qu'est ce que tu veux je suis allé
à la garden nef d aller à la gare de
l'est à paris chez lui à l'égard de
neige n'allait pas rester sur trottoir
toute la nuit papa bon alors
en arrivant à la gare saint lazare mais
à la gare de l'est à la gare d'un car de
l'est en indiquant la gare de l'est
j'ai pris une chambre wiimote et au
terminus m'ont dit c'est bien c'est bien
oui il s'est passé pas mal oui c'est mon
idole au courant il zoome locaux locaux
et puis en ce matin je me suis levé et
est toujours toujours pas de taxis non
mais il doit il doit y avoir une grève
oriali a toujours une dame il ya
toujours voilà enfin finalement j'ai eu
de la chance j'ai trouvé un fiacre à
cheval kalo au ranelagh sa mort qu'est
ce que tu veux un fiacre pour traverser
paris sas amara ça m'a pris deux heures
leur arrivée portes samedi quand même
j'ai demandé aux cochers s'il pouvait
pas aller un peu plus vite
c'est inattendu s'estiment abandonnés
qu'est ce qui t'a répondu une coget et
bien il m'a répondu
il m'a répondu il m'a répondu si vous
croyez que pour trois balles vont nous
faire faire des boulevards ou pas
espagnol alors qu'est ce que tu veux je
n'ai pas insisté
un nom mais ils s'embêtent pas ces gens
là pour vivre heureux vivons cochet
[Rires]
voilà à quoi tout arrive même les fiat
et menacé
mais pourquoi es tu es tu dors c'est
tard après la fermeture du métro ni
pourquoi es tu es tu dors si tard après
la fermeture du 10 mai pour était déjà
perdu oui mais mes passes mais parce que
mais parce que mais parce que j'ai
travaillé mais c'est travailler voilà
j'ai passé ma nuit à la alors plus vert
j'avais des épreuves à corriger je n'en
sortais plus ça m'a pris jusqu'à une ou
deux heures du matin voilà notre corps
plein ils savent où tu étais avant
d'avoir commencé et ça tape à un peu
altérée certainement ce et ben oui là
oui bon bah oui je me suis arrêtée deux
petites minutes dans le premier petit
bistrot venu chez maxim's mais promet de
soi gp une citronnade les citrons sont
chers ah oui 300 francs une citronnade
quoique ils ont reçu la note avait
touché 1 on était plusieurs à nommer dit
que non mais dit-on mais c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible ça dure on
n'a jamais vu autant de chats ça c'est
pas possible alors émis comme au sud des
îles ne sais pas mais moi je serai moi
même
moi j'ai s'annonçait beaucoup trop il
faut pas payer on vous vendre est ce que
tu te moques de 12 mois
non content de passer tous deux traduits
dans des endroits lellouche suis maman
au moment du moment tu vas pas me vanter
le rassure toi je serai brève mon
histoire messieurs les juges sera vrai
bon bah je veux m'asseoir ordre et je te
prie de parler poliment à ton père mais
c'est à toi qu'il va renoncer à bout de
cette aventure
voilà allez vas-y moment je t'écoute
d'abord se défend de dormir comme
s'adresse à paroles je ne dors pas je
ferme mes gobbo grands yeux noirs pour
mieux entendre voilà
recueillie sur l'îlot accueil écoute en
avant il n'y a qu'un mot pour qualifier
l'existence que tu mènes n'allait
révolte en révolte en révolte un bon
gars et moi nous en sommes c'est curieux
je dirais même plus nous en sommes nous
pas très bien et coûtent moins chers
enfants pour je veux tu en voilà un
moment je t'adore tué délicieuse mais
vraiment ce matin j'ai pas le coeur à
t'écouter 1 j'ai déjà tellement d'ennui
du tu as désormais quel ennui
à bab été super toi à toi tais toi tu es
superbe quoi alors je suis pas rentré de
la nuit je pars en oubliant une addition
de 15,8 chez maxim's tu as tout à prix
tu me demande quel ennui je peux avoir
tu crois ça m'amuse alors quand je me
connais mais j'ai horreur de me
contrarier mois contrairement à ce que
vous pensez moi j'ai de l'estimé pour
vous de l'affection et et est même un
peu d'admiration non mais c'est vrai
sans blague
sans blague ils n'ont pas pas que tu
devrais pas dire maman qu'elle soit ou
non non non je dirai rien du tout maman
tu aurais pas si tu crois que le rémois
les fans notre avis ces escapades
nocturnes landing il nous disait tu
m'étonnes que kwakwa manière l'an
dernier un homme âgé comme en mai
dernier dit bah j'espère bien oui est-ce
qu'une fois par hasard tu ne pourrais
pas rester ici de ce happy to coucher
après dîner somme serait fatale maman
villa clanique on respire bien le rien
est malsain comme de se coucher tôt et
pourtant mon ami les poules
ben alors justement une boule salut 50
poule alors si ces actes une souhaite
bon alors je dors dehors un bon alors
écoute tu vas me faire le plaisir
maintenant on parlera de tout ça une
autre fois oui moment ce soit plus
aujourd'hui
oui mais non non non non non moi merci
paris il est mis les 35
il est grand temps que tu est habile de
magie vais aller au privé nous avons du
monde a déjeuné dit sa hâte oublier sa
petite fille mais de l'académie
ces gens là qu'est ce que c'est que ces
gens-là de licence et la première fois
qu'ils viennent
tu as plus souvent mal vous êtes
d'aubigné à houlgate était dernier ben
oui bah quoi une ou deux fois
non mais c'est pas possible de
mutualiser d'inviter ce que débris sa
petite fille pour quoi faire
il n'est jamais mauvais d'agrandir le
cercle de ses relations et ben ça va
être des les sinistres ce vieux machin
quant à sa petite amie juste avant sa
petite fille comment la trouves tu ne
trouves pas j'ai oublié non parce que je
te demande ça justement parce que ta
mère assa trouve charmante et très
intelligent me coûte moment quand tu
sais plus où il en faut ça repose je
suis pas fatigué je sais pas je ne suis
pas fatigué si justement je suis un peu
fatigué tu tiens vraiment ce que déjà un
peu mieux quand on dut sociaux moindre
invité andré va vite c'est la partie ils
ont alors alors tu ne me mets pas à côté
du vieux machin et tu ne me met pas non
plus à côté de la pucelle parce que je
te préviens je ne leur dirai pas l'amour
qui m'agace allez va c'est la 6
ça c'est la 6 à celle là ça s'annonce
bien mais pourquoi m'as-tu interrompu
j'allais justement lui dira t'on dit m à
ces trois que tu apprends pop ou cela
vraiment vous n'aurez pas voulu de
jeunes et même est alors alors alors
alors alors on va voir monsieur tout
minuit être mai
m tobin
monsieur monsieur bonjour on se remettra
pas voyager vous connaissez le rémois
bonjour mais rien n'y fait rien taillez
premiers montent un projet nommé
prenez-en grand soin et puisque vous
êtes là derrière bien élevé prenons mais
quand également et tenez vous
tranquilles comme disait sarah bernhardt
dans fedora de victorien sardou ma
petite fille n'est pas là comme disait
victor hugo
elle n'est pas vous avez tous non c'est
à dire que voilà je lui avais donné
rendez vous chez mon médecin
non non mon libraire libraires et elle
m'a causé un chapeau un lapin la
poussière la fin alors je les attends
d'une vingtaine de minutes et puis
j'avais pure des 30 ans alors je suis
venu chez vous comme un don elle connaît
notre notre adresse on moi non oui enfin
peut-être allez peut-être un cours ou
une leçon qui cependant aux non non non
m'a dit qu'il ne voulait plus suivre de
cours alors maintenant elle fait des
courses des enfants et vous lui avez
parlé de nos projets quel projet enfin
nos grands projets m'ont jamais de votre
petite fille notre fils avis oui ah non
non je dis on n'est pas vrai parce que
ce matin j'étais dans sa jambe n'était
pas si elle y était si c'est mal et
était de mauvaise humeur quoi ça oui
parce qu'elle voulait pas venir chez
vous non mais vous trouvez trop vert
alors je lui ai dit que vous ne sembliez
très agréable et que votre jeune homme
semblait plein de mérite enfin j'ai pris
vos sachets prime autres partis auraient
nous verrons bien aimé passer justement
ce que disait ma femme
ah bon vous êtes mariés oui oui c'est ce
que disait ma femme parce que figurez
vous que aujourd'hui nous sommes
exactement dans la même situation
vis-à-vis de notre fille oui parce que
ce matin nous avons voulu lui parler et
juste milieu est pas bon
quand une union est aussi judicieuse
aussi assortie de celle ci car elle n
est ce pas ranger remise des prix vous
aimez faire des mariages faire le
bonheur des jeunes c'est une manie chez
les vieilles femmes vendent incertaine à
mais je pouvais volant par les brahma
vibrateur le mariage ce matin étaient
des guerriers mau ben bongo le mariage
aider le mariage est bon comme disait le
poète à la fin nous verrons vie rêvée
ont des envies d'ailleurs
l'histoire est plein de ces faits en
effet me j'ai écrit il ya quelques temps
une conférence sur le l'union conjugale
depuis 15 sans qu'un marine y ont mis
jusqu'à l'exposition 1900 1908 et je me
souviens avoir écrit mme therrien dont
je suis assez fier et qui commençait
comme ça si l'on considère si l'on
cautionne à 54 ans mademoiselle jeanne
howe
[Musique]
ares vous remercie vous gagnez il est
effrayant un message vous avait prévenu
il est fatigué ça y est il est de plus
en plus fatigués mais spa vous êtes
fatigué m un vrai bon jour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur je vous ai vu un regard
sur le net
non je rappelle mathieu bien tu vas
trouvent les doigts sales fait rien je
ne commencerais pas plein coeur et l'âme
et dieu en guerre je sortais du café
américain sur le boulevard j'étais allé
prendre porto avec les aubert que
j'avais rencontré les obèses c'est un
petit ménage tout neuf
la jeune femme était une camarade de
pension à moi s est marié il ya huit
jours alors vous pensez qu'elle en a
l'air
ça suffit en fait oui mon fils m'a dit m
qu'est ce que je vois une espèce de sale
individus en train de rosser à tour de
bras
un malheureux chien jour qui hurlait à
fondre à la si l'on considère les mots
tu ne fais ni une ni deux je me
précipite vernet je lui dis monsieur je
vous défends martyrise de cette bête de
quel droit je suis de la société
protectrice des animaux
c'est pas mal de saint julien et le
voilà qui fut même traité normaux et de
quoi je me pose que son chien est à lui
qu il a payé
là je la rete vous l'avez payé combien
50 francs
je l'achète somme de l'hérault
il hésite hi-fi il me dit beaucoup
cbp du co2 par habitant
alors comme vous n'avez pas les 100 fois
je les ai emprunté en verre et j'ai payé
bonheur
j'ai dit à ma mère que tu lui rendrait
les 100 francs n'oublie pas si l'on
considère ben c'est pas besoin de dire
qu'il s'était fait tout un rassemblement
quarante personnes au moins qui injurie
le type qui monta que la nuit j'ai eu un
succès il ya un vieux qui voulait
m'embrasser
donc je les en empêcher et puis un petit
pâtissier qui m'a dit que j'étais
rudement ou attendez donc annonc
département quoi deux départements
pyrénées orientales
non c'est bon ça bref ça peut être
giraudeau et le chien je viens avec moi
dans un taxi mais ils avaient faim alors
je les confie à votre valet de chambre
pour qu'il lui donne à manger
il est là dans l'antichambre jeunes pas
madame donc pas du tout au contraire
est-il jolie ou un ce chien là un cadre
assez sont mauvais il a l'air si vous si
doux au balo je peux prendre un bain à
s'asseoir parce que je ne vais pas vous
laisser je dois m'adresser grand père
âgé des deux est bel et bien grèce 3
dans ma chambre tu ne verras par aol et
l'oto rhino cessera et battu en brèche
je te relis je vais risquer un calembour
comme les aimer c'est bien son beurre je
t'aurais ni dans la forêt je te renie
sous voie
non mon cher mais je ne vous présente
pas mon fils il connaissait déjà
ah oui ah bon bonjour monsieur aux
médias n'ont jamais monsieur jamais être
toujours mais à condition ne m'appelle
pas mettre maintenant m'appellera gamme
est il bon jour mais je vous êtes un
vrai petit ange avons mieux pour nos
projets quels projets et abris avec des
si quant à mademoiselle jeanne je sais
qu'avec andré ce sont déjà des amis à
bonbons ah bon bah oui bonjour n'ose
aller bien pu regarde pas ça va pas mal
merci et vous très bien ils sont
champions qui avaient des abris bon eh
ben on pourra peut-être ce soir c'est
vous mesdemoiselles ya beaucoup
savez-vous m que notre fils destine
aussi à la littérature à vous abordiez
le carrière présente bien des diplômés
dans une jolie petite fortune marie
alors il aura le temps pour attendre
l'apparition d'un heureusement audard
que j'ai quelque chose entre un maître
village et j'oublie tout le temps tous
les mois un roman un roman en vers
rendez vous seulement je les écris à la
machine à pourquoi bas pour qu'ils
soient tous pareil parce que quand
j'arrive au bout de la ligne ça sonne
comme ça je sais que le verre est fini
et je passe au suivant
vous avez fait apparaître quelque chose
en librairie bowie ont rien d bettiche d
arthur en paye ton premier roman
ohlendorf allen d'or lui a édité son
premier roman
ça m'a coûté 3000 francs comment est
intitulée 20 ans d'après avec deux pays
où les amours d'une blanchisseuse là bas
me bats mon dieu ça détend bas de la
jeune fille il ya peu
vous ne voulez pas que la température
s'est singulièrement rafraîchie de
weezer est proposé que je l'avais voici
l'hiver qui s'avance la terre est
recouverte d'un des jeux blancs moto
dieu qui fait foi bonnes moeurs quand on
y pense il vaut mieux être là là ou là
où il fait chaud qui sait de moins mais
je vous en tirez vous de me le dire à
moins bien sûr qu'il est un des fils des
cas faut absolument que je vais devoir
son chien un chien combattent et surtout
de voir et que vous avez faim alors je
vois bien servi et bien je dis votre
grand-mère une belle aubaine
on dira rigaux
c'est ma force et ma mère c'est beau
mais à terme ce matin amabile is comme
disait virgin avec ma mère est très
sympa ouais les aimables fait vous cet
été le relais du tout non non non le ici
mais donne est en train de manger je pas
le déranger alors viens toit de sa
compagne ou non c'est pas la peine de
vous le connaissez vous alors ne bougez
pas de chaîne vient
oui voila je ne serai pas que sa mère
s'intéressait comme ça aux animaux et
ben moi non plus allez on nous en voyons
beaucoup d'examens dans l'histoire de
france
si charlotte de leur émoi
venez voir le chien des fois ce lieu
vous le voyez les tout à fait curieux je
suis de l'avis de ma femme qui était les
gones et bien produit venez parler
venez voir le chien
je vais avoir le chiffre non mon cher
mais oui évidemment le chien rossi roger
déteste les b celui-ci y sont
cordialement quand même vous allègrement
non non non non non je n'aime pas les
bêtes elles sont pleines de puces
elles sentent mauvais on a beau ordonné
à n'en font qu'à leur tête
mais puisqu'il faut y aller eh bien mon
dieu
jvc nous annonce assez de françois copé
c'est dommage mais je connais vous
pouvez le voir
eh bien ma chère mademoiselle
si vous voulez mon avis tous ces gens là
sont allés voir le chien parce qu'à mon
avis ils voulaient nous laisser tout
seul sournoisement en tête à tête sans
en avoir l'air j'ai cru comprendre aux
jouets ça a été très bien fait personne
ne s'en est rendu compte et a accepté
vous et moi bien entendu est les parents
sont décidément des airs d'une autre
génération
bah oui c'est même ce qui nous permet
d'être leurs enfants en effet attend dé
voir
non je vais pas voir le chien itoi mal
aux ailes monsieur pourquoi êtes vous
venu déjeuner ici aujourd'hui parce que
vous parents non habitée oui mais
pourquoi sont ils invités à ça il doit
mal aux ailes monsieur quand on habite
une jeune fille dans une maison il ya
déjà un jeune homme et que sur l'oise
mans les parents les laissent seuls tous
les jours tu as peut-être sans en avoir
l'air à votre avis quel est le but
départ pour moi il est assez clair les
parents ont pensé que ses enfants
on pourrait peut-être l'ena les aaa ont
la vie ensemble
croyez vous que ces belles quoi d'avoir
des ensembles de vouloir nous marque est
absurde c'est absurde et que j'étais
bien sûr que nous serions moins d'accord
là dessus pour ça que j'ai rien dit
quand ils tombent quand on va les voir
le chien vous avez bien fait tout ce
qu'on nous laisse seuls qu'on en profite
mois pour avoir une explication franche
a alors absolument appeler puisqu'on
veut nous marier qu'on soyons bien la
campagne à faire sinon j'aime les
situations nettes mais toi moi aussi
j'en reviens pas vous savez j'étais
arrivé ici bien tranquillement mois en
toute innocence avec votre grand père
vous avez même pas laissant parfois mais
rien de rien et vos parents mais il
m'avait pas dit ça sinon pensez bien que
parra sera pas rester déjeuner et moi je
ne serais pas venu mais tout de même
c'est un peu fort on va moi je sais pas
moi il me semble que si si nous devions
nous marier c'est avant tout nous deux
tsars gare de rennes 1 1
vous avez envie de vous marier vous moi
mon pauvre monsieur c'est à dire que
quand on prononce devant moi le mot
fiancée je prends l'autre toi à haubans
mon geste est identique identique eux
j'ajoute que ceci ne vous concerne pas
personnellement moi je ne veux me marier
avec personne un camps ce serait ma
propre soeur je ne voudrais pas sabine
ce nom d'ailleurs comme ça y'a pas de
problème
puis enfin moi je sais pas moi mais si
on doit se marier me semble qu'on doit
être d'abord en relation c'est la
troisième fois que nous rencontrons
voilà bien aidé par an fernando les deux
êtres qui ne se connaissent même pas oui
mais qui connaît si bien les joies du
célibat parce que je vous dire une bonne
chose mademoiselle la liberté il n'ya
que ça et liberté chérie ma vie de ne
pas avoir pris la bastille a bavé moi
aussi ce monde s'accroche à la rentrée
quand on veut pas rentrer du tout
ennuyeux les parents pourquoi n'habitez
vous pas tout seul pour un garçon c'est
ta nuit
bah je vais vous dire noël c'est parce
que j'ai pas de sous mais les gens
gagnent pas alors avoir une maison à soi
servait ne tandis qu'ils ciblent
finalement je suis logé nourri blanchi
puis relativement entretenu on en direct
peut-être plus fort c'est consomme je
pourrais être très riche nom associé à
6,6
cécile figurez-vous que l'année dernière
une vieille tante à moi la conteste pré
en pail est morte en blessant six cent
mille francs
tu devais le mac est oui et oui
seulement son testament stipule que je
ne pourrais toucher cet argent que le
jour de mon mariage
croyez vous qu'il ya des gens qui ont
des idées baroque et vous ne vous mariez
pas au repas puis j'ai bien pensé mais
c'est impossible
pourquoi obama pas parce que au plus
après tout je peux bien vous le dire à
vous ça n'a pas d'importance
ben je vais vous dire ma dose elle moi
je suis plus un enfant ma vie est faite
mais oui il ya dans ma vie une personne
mais une personne que je ne sacrifierai
pour rien ou highway
or une personne fort bien fort bien et
elles jouent au bord
non au théâtre au théâtre n'ai pas vu la
pièce du palais royal et ben dans le
ballet des légumes
elle joue le rôle du père si le rule est
court mais mais il est piquant mais
pourquoi ne pouvez-vous pas c'est
impossible
elle est prise marié bat non pas
précisément mais elle est entretenue
bah voilà si vous voulez c'est ça je
comprends mais alors vous comprenez
pourquoi je la célibataire c'est bien ce
que vous faites là vous avez du coeur
donc j'ai des principes par exemple à
votre place moi je sais bien ce que je
ferai ah oui vous feriez vous dire en
face à ces programmes c'est le chien qui
a mordu monsieur lobbying et hop
oui un coup à la main accusant le gore
il a évolué de caresser ce maïs est pas
là et puis il n'aime pas les bêtes le
chien a dû sentir j'ai voir maintenant
c'est inutile tout le monde s'en occupe
moi je venais chercher du taffetas
d'angleterre que voilà vous dérangez pas
sur tout vous dire je pars ça vous fait
rire a coûté ouidah c'est trop drôle là
franchement alors là vraiment on jamais
être venue voir les chiens venaient
vraiment charmant
venez voir le chien n'a jamais cherché à
betty va voir le chien élire non gras
ces somptueuses à l'ehpad coeur fondu
dont bas du contrat il ya deux minutes
fait qu'est ce que vous me disiez lie à
2001 j'ai plus j'aurais dû l'écrire
attendez voir amélie m'avait dit à votre
place je sais bien ce que je ferai ah
oui ben alors allez-y dit moi je vous
écoute c'est bien ça à votre place je me
marierai pour rire pour pourrir je veux
dire que je ferais sans blanc me marier
à partager l'héritage ça bien sûr qu'est
ce qu'elle demande en somme notre tente
ta mère est un curé a remis mais
exactement un an exactement
vous savez qu'elle est morte les filles
personne n'avait jamais voulu d'où ce
testament vengeance elle a pensé qu
ainsi il ya une jeune fille de plus qui
qu'ils se marieraient et qui sans ça ce
rat masqué pour bon bah voilà
mais donnez lui donne une leçon vois ça
j'ai peur qu'elle n'en profite plus et
ça ne fait rien épouser sa jeune fille
mais en la laissant tout de même pour
qu'on prenait la fortune est resté
fidèle à pas la personne de votre si
elle vous aime et le pourra vous
approuvez petit ton mais c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites là alors
si je vais encore jamais pensé à ça moi
les hommes ne pensent jamais rien fait
ah bah oui mais il ya quand même un
petit problème bas pour se marier faut
être deux c'est à minima
oui seulement malheureusement moi je ne
suis qu'un non je ne suis qu'un et elle
me paraît pas facile à trouver la
complice de parce que vous savez moselle
moi je voudrais pas moi je voudrais pas
rouler une peau fille qui m'aurait rien
fait ça vraiment non
alors il faudrait que tous fassent
d'accord naturellement je l'épouserais
pour rire comme vous dites et et alors
ça ça me parait que c'est un moment
délicat donc à brec'h
à moins que vous ne consentent yevou ah
non c'est impossible
ah je ne suis pas libre c'est pourquoi
et moi aussi aviez fait
expliquez vous je me suis promise à un
homme que j'ai je ne peux pas épouser
pour le moment mais qui m'attend et j'ai
juré de n'être jamais qu'à lui si m
quand vous pouvez pas l'épouser pour le
moment parce que c'est un homme de
lettres
mais quinze jours avant de connaître il
a écrit dans une revue des choses pas
très aimable sur mon grand père il l'a
traité de vieux mammouth de débris
croulants on vous l a pas été très
aimable à vieux débris à faribault
toutes les vérités sont pas bonnes à
dire mes valeurs a voulu que cet article
lui tombent sous les yeux et voilà qu'un
beau matin
moi qui ne connaissait pas cette
histoire je vis a tranquillement trouver
grand père je lui dis que je voudrais
marié que j'ai rencontré un jeune homme
charmant plein d'avenir qu'il viendra
lui demander ma main que je donne mon
consentement que je compte bien sur le
sien et qui s'appelle est non janvier
alors là à grand-père bondi qu'est ce
qu'il fait ce genre 10 des articles de
documentation historique grand père est
il écrit dans la revue mondiale
oui grand père s'appelle jamais moi
vivant tu les prends cet individu c'est
un album et si j'ai un conseil à vous
donner c'est de ne pas trouver à
apporter ma botte mais je pensais que sa
fureur se passerait mais pas du tout
aujourd'hui encore ce nom de jean vigne
trois paires devient violet et pique une
crise de nerfs il dont ça doit pas
l'arranger à iberville un désespéré j'ai
envie les parties de faire le tour du
monde en ce moment il est athée ou une
tpe ou ce témoin des faits au mexique
attend il m'écrit pour me demander des
nouvelles de grand père je lui réponds
qu'il va bien alors il est très
malheureux et nous attendons ma majorité
seulement dame
j'ai à peine 18 ans habillés une jeune
fille les majeures qu'à 25 ou de
marieront dans sept ans là bas dit dans
ces gais pour gens vivent les pauvres
droit je ne dessèche dans la tente mais
à midi dont crocro on médite dont
mademoiselle monsieur alors si je vous
donnais le moyen épousé votre jour dit
il avant la fin de l'année qu'est ce que
vous feriez vous envoie serait ça
j'espère bien mais vous le prendriez
moyens bien sûr c'est impossible
j'ai tellement mineurs attendez vous
avez déjà lu le tome c'est pas mon livre
à moi non plus je vais quand même vous
en citer un article
le mariage émancipe de plein droit des
uns c'est pour dire inverse explique un
peu tu est extrêmement simple si vous
étiez n'auriez plus besoin du
consentement de votre grand-père pour
pour épouser leur vie pas du tout
n'auriez plus besoin que du consentement
d'autres mari et mon mari se serait pas
exactement mais c'est adele a à le
commencer par el bulli dire que c'est
génial oui dit j'ai tout à l'heure que
les hommes ne pense jamais à rien va
pour une fois je pense que j'ai pensé à
quelque chose c'est une des plus belles
idées de la saisir ben voyons voyons
précisé du ballon c'est très simple nous
nous marions pourri baba évidemment un
bon nul du morceau pour devra me par
bleus mais tout de suite après
quand vous voudrez mais sous quel
prétexte il faut des raisons pour
divorcer tout cela pour moi consentement
mutuel
attendez attendez attendez mieux que ça
mieux que ça non consommation
non consommation bref ça veut dire que
je vous aurais pas consommer
voilà vous êtes sur sa chute absolument
cyclone a commencé comme mode on voit la
ruche et le voilà libre voilà
indépendance musulmans si poma gabri non
non non c'était pas tant ils ne venaient
pas trop fort qu'est ce qu'on dit au
monsieur
on dit merci vous savez monsieur vous
vous rendez laséristes énorme et bae
coûter chère mademoiselle ce qu'il
enlève du mérite c'est que finalement
vous m'en rendais un équivalent n'en
parlons pas je suis trop contente de
vous faire plaisir
bon alors s'accordent aussi à il
faudrait peut-être que je crains c'est
que j'en dis oui mais il est au mexique
tuant vie et oui mais les lettres
arrivent non mais oui mais en combien de
temps non non non non alors moi votre
plage fuite et les tirets me marie
février avec andré marcel novembre avec
vous soyez la fin octobre
il comprendra très bon il est pas
intelligent il faudrait ajouter que je
ne serai votre femme que de nom c'est
important
bah oui c'est important ce moment c'est
extrêmement difficile à exprimer en
style télégraphique sa non non non
écouter mois à votre place je lui
laisserai la surprise il du câble aurait
simplement revenir
vous croyez mais naturellement même mais
imaginez sa joie quand il va découvrir
tout ce que vous êtes libre divorcé et
mais je sais ce que c'est tafer 18 ans
je suis mes pièces mais bien sûr écouté
ma dose est changeante sur alice vous
êtes un chic type
si vous êtes un chic type bon alors on
est associé c'est à traiter que nous
signons le classer d'auteuil je signe à
temps là c'est plutôt facile 6 semaines
à moi c'est magnifique ça c'est
magnifique pour dit on dit ton type non
on va d'abord être fiancé mais naturelle
s'étendant cette histoire est donc et
jusqu'au mariage vous allez faire
semblant de mai mois pour que singapour
nos parents on va tout de même pas les
mettre au courant
ah bah oui il donc ils croient qu'on
sait marie sérieusement un passage est
absolument indispensable indispensable
bon alors alors mon rasoir tous les
jours ça vous ennuie un bain non pas du
tout ne vous trouve très gentil moi on
vous a jamais dit que vous ressembliez
la cléo de mérode jamais oui ça m'étonne
pas lui ressemblait pas du tout enfin
vous êtes beaucoup mieux qu'elle quelle
femme trouvée bujari quelle femme je
tourne je bois je sais pas moi je vous
fais non mais je vous demande ça pour
connaître un peu vos goûts puisque nous
allons nous fréquenter pendant quelque
temps que nous sachions au moins à peu
près qui nous stoppe moi j'ai peur que
des araignées j'aime la musique surtout
les airs anglais je mange de tout
accepter des épinards et du fromage
mon coiffeur s'appelle jules et ma
manucure germaine va bien ça j'oubliais
je danse très bien j'adore ça alors ça
ça tombe très bien parce que moi aussi
dense très bien pour assister à la
nouvelle matrice vous les connaissez
bien d'islamophobe
[Musique]
geopolitis qu'est ce qui se passe sur
parents mon cher leur mémoire mon cher m
j'ai l'honneur de vous annoncer mon
mariage avec mademoiselle chapeau
à
au plan
[Musique]
voilà madame le rémois marché mais
quelle marche un savon frères c3 que ça
m'amuse passé pour la femme de leur émoi
robot qu'est-ce que ça peut bien le fait
qu'on fait trop séduisant toile aurait
moi ben dis-donc mais il est bien
conservée pour son âge a pour l'ami non
non et couché riz alors là non un choix
raisonnable je pouvais temps mais tout
de même pas d'emmener ici en tant que
mademoiselle gabriel à vis du théâtre du
palais-royal ma maîtresse qui mariée
mois aux mariés un baby oui bon dans
certaines conditions c'est entendu enfin
il n'empêche que je suis ici avec ma
femme en voyage de noces or je tenais
convenez avec moi tu le sais bien ça
alors pour me le permettre le rémois et
toi vous avez bien voulu jouer cette
petite comédie comprend au moins 7 est
indispensable ouzou ça m'ennuie pas
pouvoir tenir mon mec il faut toujours
faire attention parce milliards de
portables de bennoo mais au contraire de
ces charmants ce charmant mais pour
mieux s'aimer il faut trouver quelques
petits obstacles
1 on est beaucoup plus content quand on
les a vaincus que quand on les a pas
rencontrés où il n'y a pas de gêne y'a
pas de plaisir
à propos tu est lourde
tu es heureux comme ça mais mes chéris
je suis excessivement heureux
nous sommes à monte carlo c'est une
ville magnifique on est avec des amis
charmant il fait un temps prodigieux
j'ai tout pour être heureux moi même
mois le surtout toi surtout toi mais
comment peut-on imaginer que je pourrais
être heureux si je t'avais pas avec moi
tu sais que ça m'a été très difficile de
venir
le baron ne voulait pas mais c'est
quitter paris bah oui bah oui quelles
raisons que tu donnes évident je lui ai
dit que j'allais passer quelques jours
auprès d'une vieille tante à moi qui
sommes à la vitesse de près ans
et donc j'espère bien à jour hérité ces
métiers là gabriel je t'aime parce que
tu es intelligent ça c'est vrai nom quoi
quoi que tu es intelligent vous oui
alors tu m'aimes
mais ne me le demande pas qui n'en
croira que tu es bête jeunes comme
vaincus mais faites n'ont qu'à une
paisible et moi qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire de déjeuner et qu'elle
déjeunait oui avec ta famille ici
pourquoi le déjeuner vous pas avec nous
tous comme d'habitude la salle à manger
parce que toi je dois poser sérieusement
avec jeanne de courage aux commandes de
quoi de quoi de notre divorce du retour
de son fiancé du du temps qui nous reste
à vivre ensemble en fin de match ou en
fait quand comptez vous vous séparez
messieurs rusher ruche rue jetté déjà
expliqué cent fois que pour obtenir le
divorce
jeanne comptait se servir de la non
consommation de notre mariage et bien
faut un laps moral je dirais même plus
un laps légal l'aps bon écoute
une jeune fille ne peut pas décemment le
lendemain de ses noces allez trouver qui
de droit et lui dire monsieur le juge
divorce et moi je suis vierge mot
nombreux non non non le juge de répondre
et à étudier toute et madame attendait
un petit peu vous ne serez peut-être
plus ce soir il ya des jours où un mari
n'est pas en train
l'abstention ne devient une injure qu'au
bout de quelques temps ses quais je vais
continuer à être madame le rémois mais
sinon vous imaginez ça me fait plaisir
ah ça y est tu te plains au site web
afin nettoient la place belle à deux ou
trois jours que j'ai rencontrés dans le
hall de l'hôtel
une petite femme délicieuse et qui m'a
plu oui qui m'a plu alors ce matin enfin
j'ai réussi à lui parler elle m'a arrêté
tout de suite il ya rien à faire on le
pour moi jamais d'hommes mariés
c'est un principe trouvé ça drôle
mais qu'est ce que tu vas faire ici
d'abord je suis venu chercher ma femme
sauver les apparences et découvrir tes
turpitudes
je me fais que ça comment ça commence à
commensacq ans jeanne mas vu arriver à
la terrasse du sea rose
elle m'a aussitôt demandé où était
gabriel à la ferme je lui ai répondu
qu'elle était restée avec toi et pas
très bien oui peut très bien il a un peu
tiqué
as tu crois ma peine la fin on sait
jamais alors comme je suis un ami moi un
vrai mais oui non
quand tu embrasses bien et on va dire
alors comme je suis allé me disais je
suis venu vous chercher
voilà c'est gentil suis comme ça se
passait très bien et puis pour tout vous
dire le silence et porto savoir qu on a
quoi quoi qui s'il est il qu est ce que
j'ai dit j'ai du portier de chelsea rose
avec des vérités pas il est un fait et
celui ci est bien meilleure c'est
effrayant ce qui peut boire c'est être
là quand tu seras mort leur ai moi je
m'occuperai taton au mercy pourquoi
parce que je connais tes gauche devrait
faire une dalle en pente mais dit tout
de suite que ce soit un livre 'le louis
leblanc en encore quand je pense madame
non ma chérie mon amour je vois mon
trésor quand je pense que pendant un an
je n'ai bu que du lait comme ça l'année
de ma naissance
allô t'es trop bête ya la passion des
preuves que ce soit aux barrages et pose
un tout a tourné ce montant tient
surtout à la femme vous dérange pas du
tout cas l'idée m'est venue tout voyons
quelle idée chère à mikkeli desquels
vidéo on peut déranger et quelquefois
deux personnes mais trois je suis là moi
oui bon et ben mes enfants nous allons
vous laisser des jeunes et ça vous venez
madame
à tout à l'heure
chers amis si jamais une balade avec les
ébats plus rémois sa femme et vous remet
aux spaghettis doit venir me prendre
pour aller à beaulieu et ce soir je dîne
avec richardson au palace eh ben c'est
très bien très très bien il a été
sympathique un sweatshirt je ne connais
pas beaucoup mais ils sympathisent et
très gentil mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya des
jeunes et order poulet petit point ça la
glace ça vous va bon là pour les servir
est ce que monsieur et madame prendront
comme dame du rouge
pas marc coma voilà ça me semble tout
drôle jamais pourquoi qualité de la vie
la mort écoutez jeanne j'ai à vous
parler vous voit jamais moi non mais
c'est vrai sans reproche on peut pas
dire qu'on soit beaucoup rencontrés
depuis notre mariage
c'est votre faute quoi vous passez vos
journées avec monsieur et madame le
rémois bon je dors pas toujours mais un
net rester qu'avant-hier au fait
qu'est-ce que vous avez donc de si
particulier à le dire bien des choses
janin le le temps passe il va falloir
prendre des dispositions pour notre
divorce
déjà c'est très gentil ça vous voyez pas
ce que ça ça prouve que vous ne vous
ennuyez pas avec moi non pas du tout
c'est vrai pas en tout cas il va quand
même falloir penser sérieusement à me
séparer
dites moi j'ai envie n'est pas déjà en
route si je passe et comment ça je pense
n'être pas sûr voilà un match n'est pas
eu de ses nouvelles
non mais attendez attendez attendez vous
l'aï déjà prévenu notre mariage je lui
ai envoyé un télégramme très détaillé il
m'a répondu quoi demain j'arrive elle
montre mais sache c'est bien mais depuis
depuis rien alors jetez extraordinaire
ça mais non oui il a dû sans marquer
tout de suite pour moi les prochaines
nouvelles que jaurès autre bandeau ah
bon bon bon bon bon vous êtes tranquille
alors un bain sur son retour
bon bah tant mieux donc maintenant plus
homme marié vous voyez qui reviennent
pas à vous êtes ben je vous aurais sur
les trois mois
rassurez-vous edmond madore il reviendra
bon d'ailleurs même s'il ne revenait pas
je divorce très basse et très gentil ça
non c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas du
doul mari qu'il me faut ah bon rossa
lorsque vous êtes un gamin
commentant comment comment j'aime les
hommes mois 1 les hommes pour de vrai
les salles fait comme on dit et vous bah
moi je préfère plutôt les femmes alors
c'est pas sérieux ou la peau de poulet
demander qu'est ce que je vous donne un
peu de blanc oui un peu de blanc voilà
donc deux blancs voilà je vais prendre
aussi un peu de blanc
alors dis donc il est il est sérieux il
sent pas comment qui ça et non jean
ville parle
quel âge at il je voulais 10,42 zain à
mes amis il est bien fait ça peut être
bien fait il est bien faire
c'est pas un perdreau de l'année et
alors que ce qu'il fait dans la vie je
voulais 10 des articles de documentation
historique
olé olé ne blaguait pas il est très
intelligent
donnez moi du vin voila voila voila mon
ennemi vous l'aimez vous qu'ils aillent
dont le nom se valent à un bon nul n'est
pas mauvais mon jean ah oui mais en
usant mais celui ci en buvant il est pas
terrible
merci beaucoup merci bien alors dis donc
et dont il est bien physiquement très
bien c'est un grand mot nas avec une
barbe majestueux une distinction rare
j'aime les barbus la tournée avec une
barbe à j'en espérais pas tant alors
pourquoi vous m'ennuyer au fait nous
parlons tout le temps denman et jamais
de votre maîtresse de ma maîtresse la
femme de votre vie
mais où est alors ce moment mais il est
à paris pourquoi elle s'appelle gabriel
n'est ce pas
comment savez vous c'est vous qui l'avez
dit un jour au début nos fiançailles
ah ouais euh gabriel en effet c'est ça
gabriel lui même prénom que madame ne
rêvera le mec ne m'aiment pas n'ont que
ça c'est drôle je m'en étais jamais
aperçu c'est un très vieil ami à tous le
rémois
le rémois ah ben non c'est que du tout
crif selon lui il est restée pim moi
j'ai grandi
la voilà enfin c'est c'est un très vieil
ami e le rémois
vous avez beaucoup des petits points
donc je ne m'en voudront pas dommageable
c'est un monsieur un grand monsieur tout
rasé qui demanda par madame marseille
ses spaghettis il est toujours en avance
au guidon ce peut être un poteau là
quand même nom dit là ce monsieur que
j'ai un déjeuner d'affaires avec mon
mari et que je ne peux pas le déranger
bien madame et 1h05 à quelle heure lui
avait donné rendez-vous à 2h15 bon alors
il parle à nos chances sont là où je me
suis insiste pour voir madame
immédiatement aux oignons n'est pas dit
que j'étais avec mon mari
si madame justement elle en est devenue
tout pas il m'a dit raison de plus
renvoyer le mari avec madame dans soit
être quoi je n'ai pas dire aux employés
le mari j'ai dit que le mari sans âme
mais qu'est ce que c'est le grand
monsieur tout raté
et depuis et depuis j'ai réfléchi rester
monsieur j'ai à vous par mes jambes
majeur qu'est ce que c'est que ça ce
n'est rien c'est votre vie c'est la
moitié de fumel c'est en ville je me dis
ah bah oui mais il faisait si chaud là
bas qu on met ça va bien mon avis
laissés nous que je vous présente mon
mari ch
mon fiancé je suis enchanté mais tout à
l'heure qu'est ce que c'est que ce à
quoi ça
soyez heureux n'attendront pas sept ans
me marie dans un mois avec monsieur
andré marcel je divorce dans deux mois
revenez vite je vous épouser dans l'oeuf
jeanne qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais
comment tôle on ne souhaite une faute
d'impression
je vous ai pousse dans neuf dans neuf
moines dans neuf mois il montre les
alors alors quoi c'est fait
moi non vous savez ces poussées monsieur
ah oui monsieur mais aujourd'hui jour
oui oui
[Rires]
310 me suis étonné et tenez bon tenez
prenez m'en prenais mon mouchoir
monsieur tenez voilà vous n'êtes pas
content vous nous remerciez pas monsieur
marcelo ne restait que deux fois et de
navarre imaginer mon mariage avec lui
vous permis d'épouser citant plutôt oui
oui oui mais divorcer les truies va
comment flétri aux jeunes majeurs vous
piquez monsieur mémoire de ma vie vous
pas promis que quoi qu'il arrive c'est
avec ma que enfin que je serai le
premier qui te donne le premier qui que
quoi
je suis plus que l'autre ce qu était
second j'ai compris ce voyageur ayant
des clauses du traité d'auteuil
voilà deux sexes à le traiter d'autres
mais cher monsieur le traité de nice et
une convention qui vous permet d'écouter
lambie - divorcer mais attaque attaque
donc de black lady droit non je veux
dire c'est un rêve
pourquoi mais alors
mais alors vous avez respecté votre
femme al anon monsieur non pas ma faim
votre fiancée ennemi attention c'est bon
je veux dire c'est un sas est un malade
c'est un fait ni donne non non je veux
dire c'est un saint
monsieur monsieur vous êtes ce1 ce1 ça
si vous monsieur vous êtes un homme
monsieur je ne saurais trop trop vous
communiquer mon pour l'admiration et
mais ma reconnaissance
mais du tout monsieur c'est tout naturel
tout ça c'est trop heureux d'avoir pu
vous être agréable mais voilà mais je
vous en remercie il n'y a pas de quoi
où aller ou allez vous monsieur je ne
sais pas mais j'y vais tout droit ah bon
il ya encore quelque chose qui vaut pas
occuper cieux oui oui c'est une idée qui
excusez moi excusez moi monsieur
il me ramenait mais jusqu'à ce jour vous
ne me connaissez pas après du tout donc
si vous avez eu cette conduite
cornélienne c'est uniquement pour une
obliger un individu indifférent un
inconnu mais pas du tout monsieur pas du
tout pas du tout relisez le traité
d'auteuil on relisait traité d'autant
que je ne connais pas et ben écoutez il
y est dit que du fait de mon mariage
améliore sensiblement ma situation
matérielle en touche en héritage de ma
vieille tante la comtesse de pré-en-pail
bonnart comme ça je comprends j'ai
compris et ben voilà il a compris entre
gens qui me ainsi par ce mariage
mademoiselle vous obligez quant à vous
vous l'obligent à tout en bavent les
gens je me suis infiniment obligé ils
conjuguent beenie man assaf d'un wagon
merci monsieur je ne ne crois pas que
les circonstances vous permettent jamais
de ma part
merci merci n'est engone depuis méditons
j'aime quand vous devez déjà avoir des
tas de choses à dire à madame
mademoiselle
ah oui oui le prénom parce que si oui si
on me le dise en face à toulouse le jeu
d'abord on le bouscule aussi dit ceci
dit ce monsieur que ceux ci c'est le bon
voulez-vous de fer l'amitié de rester
déjeuner j'attire elle va rester des
jeux d'ombrés avec vous deux noms avec
elle moi je m'en fiche je terminerais
m légumes aux légumes bah voilà match
alors nous reprendrons j'en étais aux
légumes aux légumes poissons légumes
alors attendez voir je vais vous donner
pouvait reprendre une assiette prof
tranquille et serviettes pop est un ver
profs n'ont pas de réseau monsieur
monsieur the slits conçu et monsieur
tout ça est tout à fait naturel voilà
une serviette
voilà un couvert je vais même vous
donner quelques uns de mes petits pois
sur la vitre ou d'ailleurs est ce que
c'était que ces personnes voilà monsieur
voilà alors il ne vous manque rien non
monsieur rien d'universel et bien alors
bon appétit mére à tout
merci merci à tout va il est charmant
ce jeune homme est charmant et je
comprends qu'on les traite
j'avais tant de la coupe et quoi notre
barde faisait si chaud là bas aux songes
et jeanne que depuis que j'ai reçu votre
télégramme attigan ttec je lis pour
ainsi dire ni but ni moche c'est une fin
qui sont des légumes mais son froid tu
appelé le maître d'hôtel de retirer
votre 15 ml ce que fut ma traversée ce
que fut la traversée
tous les soirs je vous imagine est dans
les bras de votre marge ça me donnait
des idées noires était minuit tu étais
blanche non tout de même l'envié plume
envoyé un télégramme du bétail et je
sais bien ça coûte 6 francs nous sommes
enfin tout de même vous avez raison
j'aurais dit oui je sais ce jeu vous
épouser dans l'oeuf
elle voulait rien dire brice comment
redonner du poulet médécin cheval barbe
et louchait je veux la commande et du
commun avant moi ton pardon c'est le
monsieur qui apprécié monsieur qui m'a
pressé mais qu'est ce que cela fait
puisqu'il me la rend un non au et du
coup les shows des shows une bouteille
de sauternes chaude
restez à votre place
imac à magas les côtés comme ça mais
pour toi avez vous coupez votre part je
vous en ai déjà dit et maintenant vous
savez tout c'est sous les coups d'oeil
d'équateur tu es bon tu fais comme ça
les fait un voyage intéressant merveille
2h dieu vous avez lu mes articles donc
bien voir du mondial du petit savoyard
chrétiens tout détruire notre signature
jeudi les yeux fermés cette phrase tombe
amoureux
[Musique]
mais comment et vous cite j'étais à
monte carlo
très simplement nous n'arrivons à paris
j'ai corrigé votre grosse pierre je leur
ai dit jeanne oui ma jeanne n'a répondu
votre jeannette à monte carlo et de
l'hermitage en voyage de noces je me
suis écrié sa prestigieuse trop tard
elle s'est mariée dans l'oeuf qui n'a
pas compris moi non plus j'ai couru la
gare de lyon hument voile merci ça va
mieux j'ai mieux
moi aussi on avait tout à fait bien
merci
mais vous ne mangez pas en était à la
salade
je vous attends vraiment moi je me
dépêche
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous savez que vous êtes toujours aussi
jolie jane le mariage ne vous a pas
changé le contraire serait étonnant oui
étant donné que alors que c'est vrai je
peux pas y croire
à coire bakou ce jeune homme n'est pas
eu l'idée de ne
après tout c'est votre mari il aurait pu
il aurait pu xe et xixe
il aurait pu exiger de vous que
maintenant je peux pas y croire
rien n'y croyez pas rob grand pas je
vais très mal il ya trois guézy beau
jeune homme tellement vous foncez bon
j'ai failli perdre du poids n'est pas
malin non il va très bien on est même
pas voilà tous deux puissent aviez fait
il est une maîtresse alors j'ai vu
comment elle est ici qu'est ce que vous
en savez mais je n'en sais rien je
suppose dammarie honoraires je me mets à
sa place possible que sa maîtrise soit
ici les rémois est allé me dévouer et
madame le rémois s'appelle gabriel
ouais ouais je n'ai pas malade si elle
n'est pas ici je peux pas admettre que
des voix serrée je voulais vous attendre
pour m'excuser de ne pas dîner avec vous
mes idées cette heure je suis obligé de
partir je dîne à menton avec les leurs
et moi un métier à spaghetti andré vous
êtes convaincu tout à fait qu'est ce que
c'est que spaghetti un très gentil
garçon
une bonne pas
c'est un drôle
le mexique ne va pas tout à fait d'un
jeu fait par un démon drôle
le mexique a fait de moi un autre en
main
qu'est ce que c'est que ce parti parce
qu'un des fleurs comment parce que
voyez-vous edmond vous au mexique
mon mari encore plus loin je
m'ennuierais amour it away alors alors
alors j'ai spaghetti jerry richardson
j'ai très simple j'ai beaucoup de monde
un spaghetti est un des plus assidus et
foreuse mois comment savez vous pas ce
qui me l'a dit c'est tout à fait
incorrect ou quoi on y voit une jeune
fille timide jeune fille manon
relisez traité de taille qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un richardson un américain dans
les huit minutes les arachides aux les
cacahuètes trou il vous fait là qu'on
n'est plus violemment il veut m'enlever
comment il me dit tout le temps et aux
armes selon mme manney canio lipson mal
il vous dit ça qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
on voit autour de mon cou vos lèvres sur
les mines coco qu'on n'essaie pas désir
qui l'expriment pas souvenir qu'il est
va passer pas souvenir qui le
oui vos lèvres autour de mon cou sera
pas très commode et le fait qu'au gré
sac un peintre français le sillage des
mois oui j'ai déjà trois personnes qui
m'ont demandé s'il n'était pas mon amant
josé qui devait laisser entendre des
choses c'est très ennuyeux vont trop
n'est pas si je trouve si je trouve fiq
et monsieur andré marseille reste à 10
dans tout ça
comment qu'est ce qui se dit bah mon
dieu c'est votre mari et tapas et du
juge eh ben c'est du propre qu'est ce
que vous dites
et oui c'est ça ce que vous appelez ça
un tact mais je suis intact physiquement
oui facialement non le mariage est une
institution sociale je vais épouser une
femme compromise
une effleuré ils connaissent leur ai je
connaissais pas ce mot la balance mais
vous ne voyez pas comme lui vivait dans
un monde inouïe où la vulgarité le
dispute à la perversion il est
incroyable que vous ne vous en rendez
pas compte
et si votre mari est un triste sire vous
vous étiez debout vous interdisez mais
nous sommes également comment les gars
encore marié je sache pour le moment je
ne connais qu'un homme qui le droit de
faire des observations
on arrive il pas dangereux en passant du
village je lui dirais deux mois quand je
le verrai et déjeuner quand libéré voilà
je dis monsieur comment c'est comme ça
que vous gardez la fiancée quoi je vous
confie une jeune fille je la confie à
monsieur andré marseille qu'on pourrait
croire un homme bien élevé donc il me
semble qu'on pourrait avoir confiance et
qu'est ce qu'il meure ou un casting
une jeune fille noyer perdu sally
jusqu'au cou dans les huit américains et
les pâtes italiennes
oui je sais vous allez me dire où
navires ont dû intacte et jean besson
soit préféré que vous la non n'aurait
pas préféré en formation ne se joue pas
si de la confiance du monde et si je
n'étais pas aussi douce dont l'homme
c'est bientôt fini
mais vous n'êtes rien si vous n'êtes
rien ne comptait pour rien n'est bon
qu'à vous êtes un voyageur qui revient
du mexique et qui est absolument
insupportable je suis absolument
insupportable et si vous continuez sur
ce ton là
rien qu'une phrase une toute petite
phrase savez ce que je fais mon nom ce
divorce quoi je le dis sans se parler
dès ce soir je sais à battre cette
foison et je passe la nuit avec ma femme
on pourrait peut-être nous consulter
consultant je ne sais pas très bien ce
que je répondrais tu as vraiment un nom
c'est exaspérant coûté shannon vous me
briser le coeur parce que je n'ai qu'à
moi vous dire allez vous promener aller
vous promener on écoute et vous ça vous
fera du mieux
madame jeu ne sortira pas dit si
monsieur moi j'ai un petit bijou à aller
vous promener edmond je vous jure que
c'est préférable c'est bon je jette
l'épongé
mais je ne m'éloigne pas
je vais dans le vestibule si vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites je prends mon
dessert alain rappo matériaux away vous
même je vais quand moi oui je vous hais
alors là bravo mais alors la raf
mais qu'est ce que c'est ça la wii m'ont
pas marre maître d'hôtel
monsieur m'a demandé de l'enlever mois
oh pardon j'avais pas remarqué monsieur
a changé de tête quoi j'ai pu le
monsieur du vin blanc si le monsieur du
vin rouge
je vais vous le rapportez monsieur webb
a dit dans ma petite jeanne vous fait à
mes compliments à votre fiancée alors la
rame entre les mois d'août aux entrées
il faut que je vous raconte à potins ah
oui je crois à madame le rémois au mieux
avec sharpless avec sharpless et
pourquoi vous ne dites ça parce que je
les ai vus hier soir dans le hall il
embrassait mais oui tu es le rémois il
était là bas qu'est ce qu'il disait rien
ils sourient et saluent
c'est très curieux n'est ce pas le
rémois on dirait que sa femme il est
tout à fait étrangère vous au moins
quand je vous raconte que sharpless
embrasse gabriel ça vous fait quelque
chose lui il rit c'est très curieux de
mais écoutez je ne comprends pas du tout
ce que vous voulez dire vous êtes super
bien qu'est ce qu'on me dit alors il
paraît que le jaune devient le carillon
un bond de moi andré s'indigner que vous
laissez sharpless embrasser votre page
web j'ai eu à prendre et que vous ne
pouviez tout de même pas me battre avec
tous les amants d'autres femmes
d'abord parce que ce ne sont peut-être
pas ses amants ensuite parce que ce
n'était pas votre femme
mais as tu lui as dit or nous savons
mieux mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit j'ai
rien du tout avait si la main non plus
venu moi j'ai tout de même fixé
bon eh ben oui la cabriolet maîtresse
voilà bon et après un retrait alors
depuis les jours vous me posez la
société de votre maîtresse en la faisant
passer pour la fin de vos amis enfin ça
je lui ai dit je lui ai dit que c'était
énorme mais vas-y toi lâche moi me
lâchement c'est justement je ne marche
pas je constate que c'est une vraie
n'est pas énorme
c'est dégoûtant enfin coûté jadida se
met d'accord ça c'est d'accord divorce
on va divorcer à wismes et divas sont
tout de suite
enfin pourquoi tout de suite pourquoi
pas tout dit baba parce que c'est
stupide on va commencer par ben qu'est
ce que nous attendions que j'envie soir
venu il est là j'adore je n'ai plus rien
à faire les boues et doit se traduire
très bien très bien ce mot vous oubliez
petites choses quelque chose c'est que
nous nous sommes mariés depuis huit
jours c'est beaucoup trop peu pour
invoquer la non consommation est bien de
trouver autre chose
ah oui quoi les voies de fait c'est de
la jalousie fleuret un public non non
non non non il faut que ça soit lui ai
dit vous gifle à il faut que ce soit lui
oui alors autre chose oui alors le
flagrant délit c'est mieux ah oui c'est
moins brutal et c'est plus amusant
m aujourd'hui les gens veulent le
monsieur qui a déjeuné avec moi le voilà
madame mais non pas celui là à londres
un monsieur du vin blanc on est dans le
vestibule il mange une pomme et pleure
je sais pas ça peut-être pas bonne
détruis de venir
immédiatement l'homme à la peau mais
monsieur phal et non je vous présente
monsieur le rémois je vous aime je peux
être à vous le plus tôt possible et je
me sépare immédiatement de monsieur qui
est l'amant de madame le rémois oui mais
quoi il ouvre le monde d'avoir écarté la
non consommation parce que c'est trop
long les voies de fait parce que c'est
brutal et nous adoptons le flagrant
délit parfois c'est amusant mais bon
c'est madame le rémois c'est la
maîtresse de mon avis hein écoute c'est
tout on va pas recommencer
elle s'est brouillée tous voila voila
vous même c'est avec cette mêlée ravi à
andre aussi ravi mais moi je suis très
content alors je vous dois mes
remerciements h f vous précipiter à des
forces que nous souhaitions tous nous
allons régler flagrant délit woods
serait pas trop asseyez-vous dangereuses
entre michel compromis sur toi on te dit
que tu as well as y es tu toi
assis toi voilà bon alors la première
question est de savoir
la première question est de savoir si
c'est vous qui me passerai en flagrant
délit avec une femme gabrielle pourquoi
moi vous êtes la maîtresse mais la
raison à la raison ou si c'est moi qui
vous passerez en flagrant délit avec
monsieur jean viii mois aux mille
visages sont fiancés je suis pour son
amant et va se rendre à me croire
plaignait mais c'est très flatteur qui
voulait qu'un divorce oui ou non mais
oui il veut et moi aussi je veux
cependant des footballeurs de sommes
d'accord ou bien gabriel et vous bien
jean ville et moi non mais attardons
alors là il ya ya un petit détail mes
chaussons la diane j'aimerais appeler
votre attention
bon appel à peine voilà n'oublions pas
que gabriel c'est madame lorraine noir
alors si elle est pincé avec toi moi
j'aurais l'air d'un abc oui pour une
once est vrai ça l'eure-et-loir et sans
abri bon bah alors alors alors c'est ça
qu'il faut passer jeanne et monsieur
jean vide
comment elle est en somme on peut t non
mais c'est mon mari qui est une
maîtresse et c'est moi qui passe au
point dans un amant jaloux ils m'ont
fait puisque le rémois de bacon poste
avec gabriel on me suit pourquoi ne
voulez-vous pas ça m'ennuie au point
vous en êtes
il n'y a pas de gabriel prenait une
autre complice en multi qui vous voudrez
la bonne non mais dites donc
non mais dis donc mais vous fichez moi
vous peut pas qu'on croie je suis maman
de la bonne aucoin est gentil mais non
n'est pas que je trouve ces c'est pour
toi la banda cas voilà je n'étais jassem
dans le secret assure fioul absolument
il faut trouver les deux complices parmi
nous sommes ne sortons pas de la très
bien alors je me mets à votre
disposition annoncée d'une idée certains
vous les voulez vous que je vous passe
avec le rémois n'ont pas pourquoi je
peux comprendre je suis la maîtresse
vieux monsieur merci bon écoutez mes
enfants vont se décider si longtemps
dans là ce soir minuit
écoutez uk et puiser toutes les
combinaisons possibles et ben alors
donné le nom au québec voilà nous disons
jaune isolé non non bien alors on
voudrait et guerrière non alors andré et
j'ai remis non
un honneur il n'est pas le bon sens et
gabriel et j'enfile comment vivez vous
en faites donc à écouter ces jeunes
hémois qui divorce faut que ce soit
jaloux mois ont peint c'est vrai parce
que nous sommes bien oui nous nous les
charmantes matin j'ai une autre idée de
leur travail quant à dire cette petite
histoire comme à nantes a rien à faire
ici d'abord alors maintenant un bon
alors qu'en tout cas je vous demande en
ce qui concerne gabriel avait en fait
monsieur oui
va-t-on enfin un jeu je monte là où qu
on se ment en fait c'est l'un et l'autre
se disent où se dit ça c'est comment je
m'en vais je m'emmêle alors voulez mon
avis maintenant vite on a une seule
chance de s'en sortir c'est tiré au sort
et oui mais oui oui nous sommes ici deux
couples bon alors il faut tirer au sort
celui des deux qui s'y collera enfin qui
dit se dévouera un bon alors pile ou
face
aussi alors tenez voilà sans le sou jeu
télé en l'air à les derniers mois gagner
bah oui c'est vous qu'on surprend on
l'avait choisi phare du nouveau site
alors attendez alors messieurs bien
d'accord mais tombe bien d'accord pile
jeanne et jean ville fasse gabriel et
moi alors les annonces un compte passer
dans les petits pois autour de vous est
insolent mais c'est pile et bien c'est
nous qu'on surprendra et vous acceptez
ça c'était convenu jean louis voilà je
vais aller trouver le commissaire de
police avait lui dire que je veux je
vous soupçonne d'avoir une liaison avec
un homme et jean vigne que j'ai été
averti par eu une lettre anonyme et que
je le prie de venir constater le délit
voilà ça va nous sembler où ça se
passera t'il dans sa chambre où est
votre chambre monsieur nulle part les
valises sont dans le vestibule et mais
mal sont à la consigne
vous n'allez pas nous surprendre à la
conso
trop de monde bah oui puis à trop de mal
bon ballon dans votre chambre à bout
alors non ma chérie dans votre chambre
enfin le nez c'est par ici
or éditoriaux ou pourquoi pas comment
pourquoi le temps que j'aille chercher
le commissaire de police et ça peut
prendre deux heures vous allez pas
rester enfermé dans cette chambre
pendant deux heures on assez dévêtue
on a fait des bêtises on l'a fait et des
vainqueurs à sa tête et vous est ce
indispensable
absolument bon alors qu'elle a pas
écoutés attendait 4 5
c'est pas tomber au moment du temps
normal non mais tu me manques ça bon
alors on voit pas carrément bêta ce soir
les corses assez bas bah je sais pas moi
voulez-vous deezer ou les boues 10
heures voulez vous dise à wba leur
disais vous obliger à en faire les
choses moi moi sur votre conduite en
prison le retour de monsieur enfin ce
soir tout sera réglé finissez mariage
absurde
nous militons mais absurde roubaix 1
pièce est venu me relancer juteux sur
mes parents m'ont forcé à l'épuiser
c'est trop fort c'est fou comme l'avait
proposé à a
ne vous faites pas encore me dire moi si
j'étais à votre place je sais bien ce
que je ferais je me marierai pour rire
un aa pour réussir tu parles
vous n'avez pas bien si je vous donnais
le moyen de pousser j'ai envie avant la
fin d'année à vous l'avez pas les ça il
va faire une bonne affaire j'ai envie
que je félicite il va faire une bonne
non mais pardon pardon tuque à briey
dont il est bien son amant un potager
est pardon pardon pour écouter jeanne de
m'exaspérer pas sinon je vais finir par
vous dire des choses désagréables mais
pas plus que ça vous n'aurez pas le
temps
ouais ouais ouais je laisse la place
c'est ça ce soir
sa compagne me fiche
mais si on nous a pas présenté mi fili
c'est juste est demongeot ville
mais faites donc comme jeanne malam le
rémois divorcé épouser celui que vous
aimez tout ça d'abord mon mari n'est pas
gênant gelebart andré c'est bon gigolo
bourg madame tel monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes là vous livrons mais qu'est ce
que vous faites là je me déshabille
monsieur 1
mais pourquoi le flagrant délit
enlacés et dévêtue or il est 10 heures
oui connaissait la jeune fille dans une
demi heure il arrête quelqu'un l'hôtel
de farine c'est alors que me rhabiller
évidemment évidemment on peut vous
rhabiller diamant surtout si vous êtes
seul ou réjeanne au jeu n'en fait rien
après notre entretien de ce matin les
partis en claquant la porte n'est pas
revue depuis
je suis promené dans monte carlo tout
seul j'ai déjà nés tout seul je n'ai
rien à manger les petits pois se
rappelle à son bon souvenir
je vous aime monsieur 10h05
mais décidément plus je connais jeunes
que je l'apprécié fin de charmante
petite femme d'extérieur à l monsieur à
elle vous monsieur avoue à votre
coupable différentes et écouter changer
de disque mais changer de disque
enfin nous peut-être je le sache a mais
j'y suis mais j'y suis allé elle dîne
avec richardson ou ça hop à la salle
elle me l'a dit ce matin des jeunes et
jolies j'y pensais que tu admires à wes
le palace à côté pourquoi il est fort
richardson
très très très très oui alors je serais
très énergique mais très poli très très
très d'aller chercher toutes affaires
cessantes puisque son mari ne fait pas
son devoir il faut bien que je le fasse
la panique temps elle va s'amuser si
vous êtes aussi à nous on est toujours
jaloux quand on aime et vous des moutons
ça je la torre jolies femmes
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
mais c'est ma femme
on m avait décidément faudra vraiment je
la regarde alors j'aurai moi qu'est ce
que tu fais j'attends jade et à oui au
fait c'est même et gabriel m'a raconté
c'est jeanne et jean ville qui s'y colle
et c'est toi qui les surplombe ah voilà
on va ça vaut beaucoup mieux comme ça à
quelle heure 20 minutes
bravo sinon maintenant que tu divorces
est ce que tu apprends un gabriel bien
évidemment évidemment je ne suis plus
son mari un an j'ai plus la peine
non mais dis donc qu'est ce que je
deviens moi alors tout ça est ce que tu
deviens oui bah tu deviens rien un bon
mon rôle est finie ah oui oui oui je
préfère a plutôt n'est assez mal tu t'en
gagner tout le temps alors oui et non
pas comment ça oui et non je commençais
mes frères c'est une femme charmante
voix ce qui m'exaspère et surtout depuis
bijoux c'est toi c'est pour son mari
pilsen bon dans le même temps à temps à
temps alors elle te plaît beaucoup
bon alors ça fait tendance à baisser ses
taux alors on est amoureux du d'ebrié
bat avec à profiter de la situation
1 c'était son mari après tout avait tous
les droits ou du moment que sa tante est
world trouves-tu disent satisfaits parce
que je le pense c'est mon rêve la parole
tu vois j'ai cité à te le dire mais au
fond je préfère des charges et ma
conscience parce que je suis un honnête
homme
eh bien je suis la maman de gabriel toi
moi mais depuis quand quel ratu
10h12 oui c'est ça mon monsieur je suis
maman de gabriel depuis trois heures et
20 minutes
non non non non non c'est pas possible
tu la crise est non monsieur je les
consoles de jeux les vu tantôt seule
nerveuse désempare est ravissante
alors ma foi j'ai commencé par lui dire
que je vais l'être gagner 500 louis à la
roulette
c'était vrai non non mais c'est toujours
avec les femmes un bon début de
conversation et tout de suite il m'a
souri
mais elle m'a dit que tu venais d'être
très désagréable mais quelle alors je
lui ai dit que cette m'étonnais tu es tu
alors comme ça deux fils en aiguille à
force de dire du mal de toi
méditons mézidon mettez un cochon en toi
pourquoi l instant tu me dises le passé
ne pouvait pas s'opposer que je ferai à
des moyennes mais tu m'as pas regarder
xx devant ce regard des mails rabat - le
vent ou moins la tête
j'ai 30 ans
alors alors ça super veilleux à l'or ça
alors gabriel et le rémois ça tu m'en
veux mais tu veux je le sentais je
savais je savais que la franchise me
brouiller avec toi ben ça m'est égal
avant cette femme me plaisent crois même
que je commence à l'aimer
je vais te dire je préfère avoir
qu'abriel héâtre fâché avec toi que de
rester ton ami et de ne pas avoir
gabriel à dieu
le rémois je veux pas mouiller avec toi
que oui j'irai même plus loin tout ce
que tu viens de me dire ça m'est égal
non si on peut dire que tu as une drôle
de noël quoi moi oui je suis peut-être
blâmable que tu as pris ta maîtresse oui
oui oui mais je trouve monstrueux quand
tu ne m'avais y pas alors alors ça c'est
merveilleux alors c'est toi qui m'as
trappe avec moi pourquoi je me veux tu
pas que tradition oblige on a faim cela
veut dire que quand tu te fais ma corps
de ses faveurs c'est donc une importance
vision que nous nous mêlons mais nos
trois ce pas là la vérité en ce moment
je suis capable attaché de l'importance
à rien parce que mieux parce que parce
que parce que je suis je suis dans des
tas d'histoires embêtant toute la grande
et qui m'énerve c'est jean villette et
stupide des choses parce qu'il a raison
ça il a raison jamais j'aurais dû
laisser autant de personnages à 1 elle
s'est compromise
moi là dedans je vais assez bien un rôle
puis maintenant c'est moi qui valent
elles apparaissent en flagrant délit 1
alors qu'est ce que tu veux qu est ce
que je suis là dedans moi je suis le
mari trompé bas même si c'est pour rien
ça m'agace l'écriture ça m'agace tandis
que gabriel et toi ben je m'en fiche je
m'en fiche pourtant ce n'est pas pour
rire c'est même à pleurer c'est quoi ce
à quoi je n'explique rien je vais
retrouver gabriel tu me dégoûtes dans le
rémois renard monsieur ma femme attend
j'ai très peur
tu n'as pas une autre énormité à me dire
non sois heureux ait pensé à moi
ah ben voilà elle édite en gironde pour
toi si tu sais la culture de petites
coupes
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas chez le commissaire non
j'y vais j'y vais oui janvier il me suit
il se dispute avec richardson
pourquoi parce que quand il est entré
dans notre salon comme une bombe
richardson me baiser les mains eh ben il
a raison pourquoi ils cherchent un
doublé et il les mains un au nom laisser
ça à janville alors oui le comice est il
bon fait chercher bon alors écoutez nous
sommes bien d'accord
nous sommes bien d'accord nous
frapperont à la porte
hognon danois ouvrait nous entrons et
nous vous trouvons en lacets et des v8
ce sens qu'elle en prenait l'air confus
un cr v ner confus génique conçu un
salaire vrai nous serons prêts bon bah
écoute et qu'est ce que vous voulez à
tout à l'heure
monsieur bon je voulais vous êtes vous
êtes à ce moment vous êtes en sommes
voilà vous déshabiller
ah bah oui aussi je viens tout de suite
comment mon veston mon gilet c'est tout
comment s'est passé nous n'allons pas
nous mettre tout nu comme ça derrière
oui
c'est la caractéristique
j'ai vu une fois raconté lit dans ce
vaudeville au palais royal
l'acteur qui joue l'amant avec ses
bretelles qui pendait au alors si
l'acteur avait ces choses qui pendait
ça suffit sortez votre chemise
bâtie temps dit on voit la déshabiller
qu'est ce qu'il a il accepte un
déshabillé de jeune fille je suis marié
à hawaï et c'est sur les conseils de
votre varie que vous vous faites faire
c'est fou
etes-vous bête il ne m'a jamais vu comme
ça moi alors je suis bien la peine sa
façade et tu sais rien
mais si je vous montrais mes caleçons
biais que c'est des caleçons d'honnête
homme c'est pas des caleçons une grue
vous êtes très agréable quand on est en
chemise blanche mise pour m'amuser bien
et moi ce que vous croyez que je m'amuse
puis j'ai froid bidon si nous sommes
comme ça quand le commissaire rentrera
jamais il ne croira vous êtes mon amant
et que nous nous retrouvons pour nous
aimer en cachette
de ton passe ce sera peut-être plus bien
nous le soyons moins aimables je sais
pas il est l'heure souriant empressé le
spi guerre est bien fait un effort il
paraît voulez mais je vous aime gens
n'ont pas besoin vous savez bien que
vous n'êtes plus qu un moment vous êtes
ma fiancée de ma femme celle qui
partagera ma vie toute ma vie j'aurai de
beaux et grands enfants
vous êtes celle que j'aime depuis
toujours malgré les obstacles et et
notre union on aura connu beaucoup mais
bien pour avoir résisté à tout cela il
faut que mon l'amour soit fort et il
laissera ni les vous le sentirez encore
mieux quand vous serez à moi vos avis
bah oui je vous demande pardon
donc vous voyez où j'en suis je dois
vous parler de mon amour il faut que ce
soit habillé parce que je vous respecte
parce que vous êtes une jeune fille qui
ma fiancée
je ne comprends mais vous ne comprenez
pas parce que vous n'avez pas passé cinq
mois au mexique avec macrophotographie
comme compagne non encore voyez vous
j'ai dit je dois encore une fois vous
parler de mon amour il ne faut pas que
je sois en chemise mais le flagrant
délit
aulas ait été vic
bon mais parlons d'autre chose
meyers abbas il faudrait songer à me
prendre sur vos genoux comme sur mes
genoux
damoiseau met en lice au nom soit dans
le dijonnais bon alors asseyez-vous ne
parlons pas d'amour je vous en supplie
par les boîtes bon voyage ouais si vous
voulez le mexique le mexique est une
république fédérative de l'amérique du
nord divisé en 27 étape c'est une région
de plateaux parfois désertique
quand cadre de hautes chaînes de
montagnes volcaniques au milieu desquels
se développent de fertile vallée
non je suis ému le tigre est pour moi
non je pense pas qu'elle a dit ça on dit
pas ça m'a dit mais non c'est en face
aux 42 est insupportable oui on était là
bien
mais reprenons
il est non le commissaire chargé de
genoux pour vous je viens
vous faites c'est préféra vous étiez un
froid s'y poser quand votre frapper les
coups derrière la fin au casse qu'il
entendrait le mexique est une république
fédérative mans en prenez au moins une
voix tendre parlez moi du mexique mais
tendrement wi fi dépêchez vous de votre
l'adulte seconde à noah welch si vous
voulez le même si le mexique compte de
nombreux gisement métallifère les
céréales ne sont pas en abondance mais
le climat est tempéré lés red ou parfois
brûlants la fièvre est fréquent en
briguant la fièvre matière à jeune
afrique a dit d'apple voilà cinq mois
que je vous attends que je vous aime
depuis toujours que de vous avoir
torturé à genoux tantôt sur l'on arrive
retard rené votre veston et puis
remettez votre bain parce que comme ça
ne me plaisait pdf
[Applaudissements]
vous plairait bocian salle des flagrants
délits vos épaules bout d'chou au
bonjour je vous demande pas comme celle
n'approchez pas s forte mais quatre
modèles flagrant délit ça m'est égal
vous allez si on recommençait levé xique
dre voulez-vous vous allez bon ben je
mange je m'en vais j'ai été maladroit
bon aux ânes le moment reste un nom il
est
janet
[Musique]
c'est ignoble
quand je pense que c'est lui c'est
janvier qui shaker et autres et c'est
moi et tout seul si vous saviez il aura
une bien bonne alors quoi eh ben je
quitte à l'instant le commissaire il
veut pas venir
il paraît qu'on peut pas constater un
flagrant délit après le coucher du
soleil faudra remettre ça demain
voilà c'est la loi où ai-je envie parti
parti moussa je ne sais pas j'ai
réfléchi je je renonce aux flagrants
délits c'est absurde et comment
allons-nous divorcer javaux créé la non
consommation mais il faut un mois eh
bien les atteindre au moins bons ballons
bons plats chauds aux mains quand mais
pourquoi cette brusque détermination
parce que ça me plaît alors vous comptez
rester ma femme encore pendant un mois
c'est ce qui avait d'abord été convenu
il m'a fait écouter depuis s'est passé
bien des choses à cacher quelque chose
quelque chose quelque chose quelque
chose le retour de votre fiancée qui
m'ont ouvert les yeux sur bien des
points assagi bois clair maintenant un
mec mais vous allez les filles dansent
effrayant pas vous avez une douzaine de
fleurs vous passer pour une femme légère
accueillant d'acquis on peut tout dire
et quand on peut tout dire à une femme
on ne tarde pas pouvoir tout andy et
qu'est-ce que je suis va là dedans
qu'est ce que je suis je suis le mari
odieux ridicule une fois ou alors les
deux en même temps au dieu est ridicule
et benjoin de plus de ce rôle là dedans
vous plus moi j'en peux plus je leur en
ai dans ces conditions là je refuse de
vous garder un mois de plus voilà alors
alors ben alors puisque vous voulez
qu'on attend de la non consommation on
va attendre
soit mais chacun de notre côté l'intérêt
dit oui pas écouté qu'est ce que vous
voulez c'est comme ça voilà toute façon
ça ça vous dérangera pas beaucoup
elle est restée avec votre votre jambe
il faut pour tous je vous prie d'aller
ces gens vie tranquille ils sont pas
encore commencé oui s'en va où ça mais
ça ne va pas il ya encore un voyage à
faire au bon et ben écoutez dans ces
conditions là nous prendrons le train
tous les de demain matin pour paris et
je vous rappelle rien d'autre en perd un
à vous êtes fait ce que voulait lui
fasse ce que vous y faisiez avant notre
mariage
1 enfin vous me ramener à les parents
comme les petites filles passage qui a
fait une escapade on attrape et formé au
passage le retour de l'enfant prodigue
coûte que j'allais vous tuer et nous lui
dirons un grand-père était à vos parents
que vous avez assez de moi
l'objet a cessé plaire je reprends ma
chambre de jeune fille mais vous qui
êtes un homme vous continuez la grande
vis tout seul est bien content vous êtes
riche et vous n'avez plus sur les bras
c'est commode et bien non mon petit ami
ce programme est fort alléchant mais il
faudra trouver autre chose alors vous
refusé tout net
j'adore monte carlo et je n'ai aucune
envie de regagner paris mais rentré ziv
si ça vous amuse
moi je reste
ah oui oui oui oui
non mais trop heureuse goût aussi un aaa
mais bien sûr pourrait faire un os tout
seul là à votre gré ça vous regarde
mais oui ça me regarde oui ça me regarde
ben pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi pas parce que vous avez 18 ans
vous êtes une gamine
vous êtes ma femme est une femme vont
suivre son mari de bord vous êtes très
amusant nous non mais vous savez j'ai
bien compris ça alors là ça j'ai très
très bien compris alors vous allez
rester à monte carlo
comme ça tout seul un toit et ça compte
la boue je trouve convenable tout ce qui
me convient
et ce qui me convient c'est ma liberté
je veux vivre ma vie vous invitons à
continuer parce que dans la formule
quand une femme dit je veux vivre ma vie
ça veut dire tout le monde ment bête
alors c'est possible
alors vous allez rester comme ça tout
seul à monte-carlo tout seul jean
protecteur et protégez vous mais oui oui
oui
socialement oui on protège pas une femme
socialement c'est albert betty dur il ne
veut rien dire
on protège une femme jalousement
jalousement ans occupait
y'en a pas gabriel vous en prie parlons
pas de gabriel équipe monte carlo demain
gabriel oui oui elle aussi elle a un
petit voyage à faire voilà bon vent
je ne voudrais pas vous renvoyez mai
mais l'état
ah oui
oui
je vous gêne non
du sommeil à
abb
dit-on eux c'est vrai vous chaussez du
36 qu'est ce qui vous a dit ça
le beau-père personne ni une idée comme
ça c'est chose du 35 ha ouais ouais
ou faites vous faire vos déshabiller
pourquoi nos peuples pour rien parce que
je les ai trop joli conte et offrir les
par ailleurs maîtresse c'est pas
son d'une petite lingère pas connu mais
très à droite assez tabac c'est ça je
vous donnerai la dre si oui bah oui oui
c'est tout ce que vous aviez à me dire
euh oui bon alors c'est bien décidés en
ski de mal c'est ça tam bon et peint
jeanne adieu leurs adieux
je regrette que les circonstances qui
dirait ça demain allez dans votre
chambre noie dans la nuit à je vous
verrai à keller et votre train ben vers
midi on verra sûrement
bonsoir un très bon soir jeunes
quoi
e peut rien
o o le traité d'auteuil ça alors là le
trac et d'auteuil alors
ca c c'est dangereux il traitait
d'auteuil à bbb nous avons voulu jouer
au mariage devenir brusquement mari et
femme
1 comme si on pouvait devenir mari comme
ça d'un seul coup mais c'était c'est
très difficile ça c'est très difficile
s'adresse à prendre c'est un garde et
les lois sont absurdes pour être avocat
pour six ans d'études pour être médecin
il en faut 8 pour être député ou pour
être mari font rien du tout voilà non
mais d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya
autant de mauvais couple et qu'on est si
mal diriger le gouvernement
non mais ça ça m'apprendra à croire les
femmes voilées se prétendait une jeune
fille a franchi moderne mais oui mais
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai du tout
c'est pas vrai du tout c'est une enfant
charmante encore plein d'illusions
délicieuse et de laiton et dont je suis
vêtements devenus
[Musique]
mon jeu à moi d'amour amamou amoureux
mais
mais c'est ma femme
et moi j'ai bien réfléchi un coin parce
que je suis bien mais je pars demain
vous verrez ça prendra mais en attendant
je suis votre mari j'ai tous les droits
j'ai décidé d'en profiter comment ça je
vais tout d'abord parce que vous êtes
charmante et je vais passer lui fort
agréable ensuite parce que vous allez
rester ici toute seule à monte carlo
vous allez tomber dans les bras de
richardson aux spaghettis quelqu'un
d'autre que cet autre va s'apercevoir
que que vous êtes enfin que vous n'êtes
pas que vous dites que et que moi je
vais avoir l'air ridicule et bat même
introspective mans je ne veux pas avoir
l'air ridicule je suis votre mari et
c'est à moi qu'il appartient que vous
appartenez qu'il appartient que vous
apparteniez que je viens couché avec
vous parler sérieusement on ne peut plus
sérieusement à lui conjugale et là j'ai
droit à la moitié de l'art et à mai mais
pas mais je suis votre mari moi je veux
pas qu'on se moque de moi je veux
patrick hull 1
et puis et puis je vous trouve charmant
c'est pas une raison
si jamais vous présenter hors de votre
chambre à votre mari faisait de couvrir
de ridicule
vous n'êtes pas familier rien à faire je
veux savoir c'est bon allez
t'attendais à quoi allez prenez moi nous
fait mon mari est au droit prenez-moi
pas tant attendu écoutez quoi un faux
pas ce soir mais je ne sais pas moi je
suis une jeune fille quand vous voudrez
alors on commence par quoi
non non écouter 1 écoutez j'ai déjà vu
des femmes se donner mais jamais comme
ça hein je me donne comme vous prenez à
froid puis je n'ai pas l'habitude
excusez moi alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
kss kss kss qu'est-ce qu'on fait ah mais
je devais vous montrez moi je confesse
je vais vous montrer moi voilà voilà
et bien moi je n'ai pas de chance ce
soir ce soir
ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait pour
qu'on se conduisent comme ça avec moi on
ne m'aime pas personne mais on le désire
on n'a pas le temps de me dire des mots
d'amour on enviait tout de suite au
geste
enfin pourtant c'est une jeune fille
pourquoi est ce que tout le monde me
traite comme une grue tout le monde oui
tellement bas qu'il mais qui était la
même à me chercher le message était là
avec jean ville savez vous ce qu'il a
fait qui saint-janvier oui il était
temps chemises eau en peignoir il se mit
à parler du mexique
il est devenu tout rouge et les membres
assez de blancs sur la bouche
il vous embrasse et oui mais c'est
abominable nous trouver je vais tuer
pourquoi en attendant comment pourquoi
il a manqué de respect
je ne suis pas votre femme
je ne suis pas à vous je ne suis à
personne je vous prie de vous tenir
tranquille alors ça ça c'est une wii
alors j'ai pas trop de noms noyer le
droit de dire quelque chose
si vous m'aimiez et vous ne m'aimez pas
puisque vous aimez gabriel au messie
chez moi la paix rue gabriel 1 elle me
trouve avec leurs moines et moniales la
voilà
oui mais oui mais là oui lui même heure
mais alors ce que vous lui avez dit
perche 1 rien rien du tout plus rien du
tout mais je vais me suis aperçu que ça
que ça m'était égal
c'est considérer
quoi
c deja
c'était que j'espérais
que janvier mais manqué de respect oui
votre maîtresse vous trompez et ça vous
est égal oui oui c'est bien mais andré
coig
vous êtes amoureux de moi soyons tous le
prouve
je viens de vous prouver aa à aa
c'est du joli petit dans le traité
d'auteuil ont beaucoup de vous en prie
les traiter c'est fait pour être dénoncé
les traités quoi l'histoire est là qu'on
veut donner raison et ben oui là je me
retrouve là voilà peut être contente
1 si vous croyez que ça m'amuse alors
je comprends ça si encore vous étiez
aperçu en même temps que moi que vous
m'aimiez onfray ça aurait encore pu
aller ça aura un très large et les
choses
vous n'êtes pas perçu que ça ne serait
pas une catastrophe vous savez je suis
pas irrésistible enfin j'ai pas mal à
s'est passé pas votre avis je ne vous
connais pas comment comment comme je
n'avais jamais parlé mais parce que je
savais pas que vous aimez mais
maintenant j'en suis sûr jeanne jeanne à
si c'était pas trop tard si c'était
encore possible si c'était si c'était
pas rater si j'aurai des choses à vous
dire quelque chose quelque chose quelque
chose je vous dirais je vous dirai
jamais jeunes dans la vie de tout homme
il ya deux périodes celle où il se
trompe c'est louis fait des erreurs des
guerres des enfantillages et puis la
seconde période celle celle où il s'en
aperçoit et où il les regrette et où les
corrigent et pas depuis cinq minutes
vient d'entrer dans la trompette
extraordinaire je prenais la vie pour
une vaste blague
il y avait qu à rigoler tout parce qu'il
n'y avait jamais en jamais en pleurer
tout d'un coup je m'aperçois que la vie
c'est pas une blague c'est pas une
blague c'est une chose terrible avis et
c'est difficile c'est dur il faut
s'appliquer pour bien la vivre mais
c'est une folie d'aller chacun de son
côté pour sa ville ses folies enfin
méjanes puisque nous pouvons soyons
toujours 2-1 ne disons plus jamais
jeunes ils ont toujours nous bien
regarder un regard de tous ces gens qui
nous entourent qui nous allons nous
allons tous ces gens là 1
et pourquoi ils ont jalousement mais
parce qu'on est deux et parce qu'on est
jeune et parce qu'on est deux jeanne et
puis enfin on n'a plus l'âge de faire
des bêtises vous rendez compte qu'à nous
deux on n'a pas ce que la cinquantaine
c'est vrai c'est un bel âge
quand je pense que dans quelques années
nous n'aurons peut-être plus aux anges
and human petit mois ci nous formons par
un couple délicieux pour qui il n'y a
personne à aa
mais le nom des lieux simplement de
montréal regarder que les cieux chat
depuis ce afin de rajeunir le monde
quand on va le trouver délicieux
s'il vous plaît en tout cas jean 10 des
cas comme ça dans le nombre vous en
trouvera bien quelques unes qui vous
plairont au jardin jeanne j'aimerais
j'aimerais tellement vous amener à moi
vous savez je sens tellement tellement
qu'on ait fait l'un pour l'autre et puis
inscrite inouïe c'est qu'on s'en rende
compte seulement maintenant ça c'est qui
c'est inouï ça on aurait dû s'en douter
pour coup plutôt bas mais le jour de
notre rencontre chez mes parents le jour
du traité d'auteuil
eh ben on va y revenir assure la jeanne
voulez vous vous disiez tout le temps
qu'on vous traite est pas en jeune fille
qu'on en venait tout de suite au geste
qu'on vous ait pas la cour et ben moi
votre mari vous ferez vous voilà c'est
aujourd'hui le premier jour de nos
fiançailles et je viens de vous faire ma
première déclaration
et il me reste à vous conquérir venez
vous allez vous allez allez dans votre
chambre et puis moi je vais je vous
l'avais dans la mienne et c'est vous
c'est vous qui choisirez le jour de
notre mariage
bonne nuit jane venue et ma petite
fiancée jeu
je vous aime
que
il ne reste qu'à vous conquérir
je crois qu'il pourra puis enfin c'est
mon avis je demandé pardon et bien de
melun à demain et pourrait venir au nom
vaut mieux pas que je reste sans
protection 1
audrey ces gens je viens dormir avec
vous
c'est pas ma faute j'ai peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons vécu devant vous
c'est tel traité mais prêté des beautés
d'auteuil de monsieur oui je me celui de
monsieur louis verneuil
[Musique]
du corps de roger à
costumes de cardwell
[Applaudissements]
l'umih danser et robert manuel
ah les premiers avec la distribution
suivante nous avons couplé par parle par
couple c'est plus le couple idéal de
deux domestiques
on ne rencontre plus hélas ou
heureusement et d'oies cendrées sonne
[Applaudissements]
ap je suis pour
côté madame 1 lille il ya le godet
maurice ou de rang
amis
philippe dumas
marie leonetti
vié arditi
ah bah oui alors c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]